so being 10 o'clock will open the work
session on House Bill 50.
which the full committee heard on the
26th
and the division heard on the 31st
I don't know if there's any more need to
take any
testimony but
the division's pleasure
of just as a reminder we can make a
recommendation of the full committee
of itl ought to pass or it can be
amended
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman I don't know what
you typically do in this committee
um do you like poll everybody and say
how do you think about this or or do I
just make a motion or you could just
make a motion if you'd like and see
where it goes okay well then I'll make a
motion of Ito
second
representative McGuire has moved itl
representative Griffin is second It Is
there further discussion
um
Mr chair I would be voting in opposition
to the itl motion I would be in favor of
OTP because I think a commitment was
made to our municipalities long ago the
state reneged on the uh commitment after
the municipalities took a action in
Reliance on that commitment and I think
at a very minimum what's requested here
of 7.5 percent for the uh future seems
um appropriate and far less than what
further comments representative Hewitt
now I I joined in that comment and I'm
also going to vote in opposition to the
motion now this is something that went
back to 1967 and came forward getting
worse and worse as it went along and I
think that the employees were
promised at back way back in the day
that the for the commitment that the
legislature made would be carried
forward so I think that ought to happen
thank you any further comment
representative McGuire I guess I should
speak to my emotions
so I I'll talk about two parts to this
one is the commitment aspect and and one
is the details of of how this bill
spends money
so
in general I think that
um things that previous legislatures did
go into law and they tend to stick
around until those laws are changed
based on current circumstances so when
you're talking about 1967 55 years ago
right
um
somehow the the actions of those
legislators who are dealing with their
current circumstances
shouldn't have
Primacy over us and our current
circumstances and what we think is right
for the people of New Hampshire right we
were elected to deal with current uh
budgets current expenses Etc and so
because people 55 years ago made a
certain decision I don't see how that
somehow
controls us I mean if they wanted to
they could put that sort of decision I
mean to make that sort of a decision
permanent or semi-permanent it would
have to be in the Constitution the
Constitution is what controls the
legislature right and and limits it and
and directs it and so on but law itself
is things that that change and and we
change it all the time and we add and we
subtract and so on so so that particular
argument
um
it doesn't sway me now to the specifics
of the bill so one thing that I didn't
realize until recently is this is paying
specifically for teachers and group two
members and for some reason
um others uh other employees clerks and
and so on are are not included and I'm
not quite sure the the rationale for
that but it's it's just sort of
interesting but in general this bill
so the way to cut tax this bill is is
sort of labeled I guess the the
um uh Property Tax Relief act of 2023.
so
but the real way to relieve property
taxes is to lower spending right that's
what we do in this committee all the
time if we want to lower taxes we have
to lower spending what this bill does is
it shifts money from one group of
taxpayers to another
right and it it does it in a way that
encourages spending not discourages
spending so in a sense this bill
um raises taxes right but if you have
more spending you've got to have more
taxes because they have to be in balance
and so by encouraging spending because
what this bill does is it says to
municipalities we'll take if you spend X
we'll we'll kick in something right if
you don't spend we don't kick you right
so it's a discount sort of on on this
kind of spending and what that does is
make people spend more on that right and
so
um if you really wanted to Simply Cut
Property Tax the easy way to do it would
be to reduce Sweat Right what we did
last time two year you know in the last
budget there was a hundred million
dollars cut from swept that goes
directly into property tax bills 100
million dollars less this one is a 50
million dollar item over the budget so
it's half of that
um and it but it but it directs you know
now we get into the spreadsheet politics
but it it essentially is subsidizing
cities at the expense of smaller
communities right because cities tend to
have more spending on
um
on teachers and fire and police compared
to lower other communities I did a
little example of
um here where I compared conquered with
my town of Epsom okay so in this bill
Concord receives 15 times what my town
of Epsom would receive
but their population is only nine times
bigger you see and they're and their
property valuation if we were talking
about property is also nine times bigger
so so our my town has one-ninth the
population one-ninth the property value
of Concord but according to this bill
this bill would direct funds 15 times to
conquer compared to my town so so so
this is essentially
a transfer of wealth from from towns
like mine to cities okay now
I would be willing may I sorry I'm just
going to interrupt you a minute the
clerk isn't here and there are no roll
call sheets here so I'm going to
disappear while you continue all right
all right well that's going to make me
talk longer rather I was about to sort
um okay
so where were we so
um
yeah so this is a transfer in that way
now compromise so I am willing to
compromise in a way that actually does
benefit cities in the same way as this
bill or very close to it
by spending this 50 million dollars
it putting it into the unfunded
liability of the retirement system
right so because the the way the
unfunded liability of the retirement
system is being paid off is
it is
um it's based on current employment so
effectively cities are paying more
because they have a lot more employees
than than municipalities rather than you
know paying it off by population or
property value if you see what I mean so
if we pay down the unfunded liability of
the retirement system faster it would
benefit
municipalities and especially cities in
the same way that this bill does not
quite identical because this bill is
directed specifically at teachers police
and fire whereas the whole unfunded
liability includes others uh other
categories and County employees and so
on right but
um that spice yes but I would think that
that is a better way of of spending
money than this bill because this bill
gives money directly this year but
paying down the unfunded liability is
paying down debt that's long term so it
doesn't have the problem of of the
unintended consequence of of of
um encouraging spending
right if the unfunded liability is is a
little less or a little more that
doesn't matter you know spending is
still is is is is not affected but it
does benefit those towns because in the
long run
their expenses will go down
significantly and the reason is when we
give money to unfunded liability
this if we give them a dollar this year
that's a dollar seven they don't have to
pay next year or a dollar fourteen they
don't have to pay the year after that or
a dollar 21 they don't have to pay the
year after that do you see what I mean
because because of the assumed rate of
growth of the of the retirement system
so I think that would be a great
compromise right pay down the unfunded
liability it would benefit cities in
exactly the same way this bill does but
not in a way that encourages them to
spend thank you Mr chairman
further comments representative Griffin
I also took my town and compared it to a
city and came up pretty much with the
same results
that representative
bound on when he did it and basically
this bill has the small particularly
evident in class two employees it has a
small
towns the medium-sized sounds funding
the large cities which doesn't seem to
make sense
so I think the compromise that was off
it is is a is a very good one where
either we pay down the swept
or we pay the unfunded liability of the
pension rather than
rather than benefit one group over a
further comments
seeing none the clerk will call the role
I'm the clerk apparently so
um representative McGuire
aye
and this is on the motion of itl
representative Griffin
representative Kim brills is absent
representative hatch is absent
representative Hewitt oh
and I will vote no motion fails it is
tied
so that leaves us in is there a motion
that
I think it's
one two three one two three right
okay
so just look at your check marks they're
not quite no I'll correct it I was just
making noises I went around yeah
but I know what the vote is okay
um
so I miss you said you had other ideas
representative McGuire as far as putting
it maybe the 24 25 million that the Bill
calls for towards the unfunded liability
or did I catch that correctly yes and um
if you want me to prepare that as an
amendment I'd be happy to do so
I would
propose an alternative concept and that
is that we fund at 7.5 percent for the
biennium
all right is that seconded
representative Hewitt second staff
is there a discussion on representative
ebel's motion representative Griffin
there's a there's a question isn't that
what the bill does it's it continues it
for basically ever unless we modify it
thank you yeah it's no problem
further questions or comments on
representative Evil's motion to limit it
to the session
to the term the term yeah right
um could I just make one other comment
um if if the representative from the
municipal Association has anything to
say if or to correct me but as I
understood her testimony during the
hearing she said that the payment that
we made to the municipalities last year
was extremely helpful for that to them
and I'm sure they would appreciate a
similar
well there's a motion on the floor so we
won't take any comments unfortunately
from those in attendance
it's been seconded by representative
Hewitt again to make it clear what the
motion is is to limit the 7.5 payout for
this legislative term
seeing no further questions
I'll ask a quick question sure so if we
voted yes to this is it like voting yes
to the amendment but not to the bill
that's correct that's correct okay the
bill is amended yep I mean if I vote Yes
are we going to say off the pass with
amendment is our recommendation to the
committee or is this amendment a
recommendation and then we vote
separately and not the best the bill is
amended
sorry
that's representative hatch so
all right so we clear it's the
representative evils motion to amend the
bill that we have before us to limit the
payout of 7.5 to the session so it'll be
a two-year payout versus continuing
right okay on the motion offered by
representative Ebel seconded by Hewitt
of amending the bill as stated earlier
representative Griffin no
representative Sweeney no
Campbell's absent patches absent
representative Hewitt
no I'm sorry yes
[Laughter]
representative evil
yes
and I will vote Yes emotion fails as it
yes representative why don't we go back
to um
the vice chairs motion that
an amendment be prepared to put the
money into
unfunded liability all right you have a
want to use the same specific dollar
amount that the Bill calls for
representative Maguire I I propose just
an even 25 million
or 50 million for the whole budget term
I guess
so right now the appropriation being
requested is 26.49 million and
27.13 so you're looking at a flat 25
I would actually prefer it to be 50
million in the first year at nothing in
the second year just because of the the
advantages of doing that
all right would you like to speak
further to your motion
I'll answer questions but I don't know
yeah the motion's been made and seconded
and now it's open for discussion
representative Eva I'm sorry Mr chair I
really wanted to hear from the municipal
Association
um but now we have a motion so we can't
unless we turn down this motion that we
um
I especially like representative
McGuire's motion I would like to hear
what the municipal Association has to
weigh in on and I know this will be
substantial I think we heard from Marty
last week that something in the
neighborhood of I think he used the
example of 50 million dollars could
reduce and he'll correct me I'll let him
correct me if I'm wrong
that it might reduce the contributions
made to or by the towns towards the
unfunded liability by as much as four
percent is that roughly correct
hopefully the year total
puts it in between
1.01.1.2 percent of a which represents
about 4 million a year for a 15 million
dollar appropriation so that again that
and that would be this permanent
reduction that we haven't found over
time
Maybe
all right I guess see we are
since a motion's been made and obviously
the numbers would have swung if I'd
allow representative Hajj perhaps in but
I will keep it the way it is in fairness
um
yeah I'm sure I'm sure you could
understand
so just so we're clear we've already had
like three or four motions
representative hatch I think I'm almost
what's up
representative evil well representative
Hedges I just wanted to clarify
something that you said if this motion
fails then we could
um hear from the municipal Association
on their
I'll stretch it out I've been known to
be a little lenient here
would you like to come forward this is
like not customary for us but obviously
there's a lot of moving Parts it's a lot
of money it has could have some great
benefits to the municipalities have
passed in my view but
um
Mrs heck well thank you for allowing me
to come for the record my name is
Catherine heck and I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association the 234
cities and towns in New Hampshire
so I don't know if I should take
questions or comment
I would comment on that bill so the
previous bill that was passed House Bill
1221 provided a one-time payment and
seven and a half percent to cities and
towns that was reported on the ms-4
so that reduced taxation because it was
reported as Revenue so that
when we tax rate was set the revenues
right minus exemptions and credits and
then you total the Appropriations so
therefore the tax rate was reduced
because we received more Revenue than we
anticipated the bill before us today is
structured a little bit differently it's
a permanent restoration of the promise
that was made back in 1967 when we all
joined and we all know the history there
group one there was a question group one
employees were never part of that system
and they're not compulsory members of
that system and that is why it's only
group one teachers police and fire
because in the original system group one
employees such as Highway perhaps or
town office staff was not part of that
original system to representative
McGuire's query on that so that is why
we don't see that moving forward because
that wasn't part of the original
promise that was made to municipalities
so this bill moving forward has towns
budgeting 92.5 percent in the state
paying the retirement system seven and a
half percent so what that means when we
raise and appropriate money what we're
asking for we don't need to report it as
Revenue because we're asking for Less in
our budget that we bring forth to the
voter so it's automatically reducing the
line so that's also another form of
property tax relief anytime
municipalities receive monies from the
state that don't have to be raised
locally that is a property tax reduction
so that connection on either side can be
made but this bill moving forward would
reduce Appropriations so what the town
is authorizing the governing body to
spend would be less by seven and a half
percent
so it's extremely helpful in either case
our cities and towns saw tremendous
relief from that with fuel oil prices
and inflation on that one-time payment
really did make a difference this year
whether it was a small town or a large
city all budgets are to scale so to
speak so we did appreciate that payment
and we are advocating for the seven and
a half percent even though of course our
member policy is for the restoration of
thanks very much for that
um seeing no further questions I'll ask
representative yay
representative Kim Rhodes
absent
I'm not voting I wasn't here for the
aye
well being six to zero motion passes
okay is a clerk state of the motion
passes uh why are you laughing
representative McGuire
representative Hewitt said something
okay all right well thanks everybody I
think it was a good debate and in the
end municipalities will be getting some
relief and
um 50 million dollars towards the
unfunded liability will move forward
with a positive recommendation to the
representative I just have a question
when do we see the Amendment language
they will draft that in the next day or
two of the LBA and OLS
Mr chairman represent Maguire
um I would hope that OLS will consider
this or or the clerk or whoever uh
Germaine so because it actually I mean
it it moves sort of the section we're
talking about and that sort of stuff
I'm sure I'll hear one way or the other
thanks
we're a little
ahead here so I think we've got about a
half an hour which we can break before
foreign
all right uh being 11 o'clock or a few
minutes thereafter like to rep recognize
the Attorney General for the State of
New Hampshire and appreciate your
attendance here today absolutely thank
you Mr chair
um good morning members of the committee
I'm John fermella attorney general happy
to be here the chair asked me to come
today just to do an overview
presentation of the Department of
Justice and my understanding is you've
been getting those presentations for
from other agencies as well so to help
guide the discussion I I brought a
couple of handouts which you should have
in front of you one is an organizational
chart for the Attorney General's office
and the other is just a short PowerPoint
that I'm going to run through that
mostly tracks the organizational chart
but just kind of guides a discussion of
an overview of the office you'll notice
in the top right hand corner I have a
disclaimer on the org chart we're in the
process of revamping our org chart right
now because we've had some some people
shift around we've had a couple of
additions so this is basically how the
office looks but it's not the official
org chart at this moment in time so I
just wanted to as a lawyer we like
disclaimers I put the put the disclaimer
up there on the top right you'll also
notice that below
um
the bottom half of the organ chart I
took names off of some of these units
that's because again we've had some
people move around and rather than try
to make sure everything was absolutely
accurate I just took the names off for
now because I think for your purposes
it's more important that you understand
the various units and the functions as
opposed to what individuals are running
any given unit at this point in time
so
I think the best way to to start off
thinking about the Department of Justice
is thinking about the roles and
responsibilities of the Attorney General
because the Department of Justice is is
a somewhat unique agency in state
government and that it really is built
around roles and responsibilities that
are given to the AG and then the AG
delegates those functions out throughout
the department
so on the second slide
you have I just have have a list of what
we think of as sort of the five jobs of
the Attorney General
the first and probably the the best
known is to be the chief law enforcement
officer for the state so the AG uh over
overseas in in a in a somewhat loose
sense all of the law enforcement
Personnel in the state that doesn't mean
other state and local law enforcement
agencies don't operate independently but
in certain instances when enforcing the
criminal laws of the state the AG can
decide to exercise control over any law
enforcement agency depending on
depending on the needs of a particular
case or a particular situation so chief
law enforcement officers is kind of the
the first job I think that people think
of when they think of the AG the second
job and it's closely related is Chief
prosecutor so the legislature has
decided to also give the AG the job of
overseeing all of the prosecutors
attorneys local prosecutors again that
doesn't mean that prosecutors throughout
the state don't operate independently
because they do but
um I think it is important and we've
seen it work well it's important for
there to be someone at the top kind of
giving a general giving General guidance
general direction General strategy
training to to all of the prosecutors in
the state and that's what the Attorney
General's office does we meet with the
County attorneys every other month so I
and and my team meet with all 10 County
attorneys every other month and we talk
about what's going on around the state
what prosecutors are facing what the
needs are where we might need more
resources where we could be be doing
things differently and I think it's a
really
um it's a really good setup because the
County attorneys again they run their
offices independently but I think having
sort of that team approach in this state
works really well not every state is
like that
and then the AG is the chief legal
officer for the state and basically what
that means is the attorney general is is
the lawyer for state government and all
three branches of government some people
don't realize that we actually represent
the judicial branch in addition to the
executive branch and the legislature if
a judge gets sued for something an
individual judge if the judicial branch
gets sued say an employment
discrimination claim it's the Department
of Justice that represents the judicial
branch so that uh that is an interesting
exercise in making sure that we protect
against conflicts of interest as you can
imagine because if we are representing
an individual judge who might have been
sued for something we have to make sure
the lawyer doing that is not also
appearing in front of that judge in
their courtroom so we we take a lot of
steps to to handle conflicts and that's
a theme that comes up over and over
again in the Department of Justice it's
something we talk about a lot something
people ask questions about often but I
think the office has a very good
tradition of figuring out how to handle
that we put up walls when we need to put
up walls I think we handle conflicts
well
the fourth sort of primary job of the
Attorney General the Attorney General's
office is public protection and this is
public protection in a broader sense
than just law enforcement
and a good example of the public
protection function is when
the attorney general and the Department
of Justice bring a lawsuit on behalf of
not any one individual not on behalf of
state government or a state agency but
on behalf of the people of the state and
there are a number of examples of that
that we've seen in recent years one are
the opioid cases that the office has
brought against manufacturers pharmacies
Distributors to hold them accountable
for for contributing to the opioid
crisis in the state of New Hampshire
another example are the environmental
cases so the drinking and groundwater
trust fund is a fund that was
capitalized with monies that were
obtained from lawsuits the Attorney
General's office brought against Exxon
Mobil and other companies that pollute
that had polluted our groundwater the
the lawsuit we brought against the state
of Massachusetts for taxing remote
workers that was brought again on behalf
of the people of the state generally so
that's
public protection and public interest
the the Attorney General's office is I
think at the end of the day kind of the
the backstop for that in the state so
that's the fourth important job of the
Attorney General and then the fifth job
is to run the Department of Justice so
that you know that the Attorney General
in addition to everything else is a
commissioner and an agency head just
like all the other agency heads that's
ultimately accountable to the governor
and Council to the legislature just like
the next slide is kind of related to
that slide but another when you're
thinking about the Department of Justice
I think it's also important to think
about who does the attorney general who
does the doj represent
and there are really two answers to that
that uh depend upon the context
in some contexts in one part one part of
our function is to represent the state
and by the state I mean state government
so again all three branches of
government individual state employees
when they're acting within their
official functions that includes
legislators that includes legislative
leadership that includes state agencies
executive branch Branch agencies from
Commissioners all the way down again it
includes the judicial branch so we
represent pretty much all state
employees and All State agencies when
acting within the scope of their
employment
we also represent
and I hit that on the next slide
we also represent the public
the reason the distinction between these
two is important is because when the
Attorney General is sort of sitting in
the function of the government's lawyer
and representing state government and
representing the legislature we are
we are an attorney serving our client we
are accountable directly to our clients
the legislature the governor the
judicial branch
when the office is representing the
public so Prosecuting crimes working
with law enforcement
um
overseeing and registering Charities
bringing consumer protection actions
enforcing the state's election laws the
office really operates more
independently it's accountable to to the
public and not as directly accountable
to the governor or the legislature in
any specific incidents of course the
legislature can also always change the
laws and give give the AG's office new
jobs or take away Authority the
legislature can make appropriation
decisions so give us money to do one
thing and not another thing but when we
are say investigating a homicide and
deciding whether or not to prosecute we
make those decisions independently we've
we've been delegated that Authority and
that's kind of the way it works in all
in all states and those specific
instances we the AG ultimately has to
make that decision on his or her own and
I think the reason for that is to keep
decisions like that that shouldn't be
political or shouldn't get tied up in
the various policy debates of the day to
keep keep those functions independent
from from those wins on a day-to-day
basis again that doesn't mean the office
doesn't still have accounted isn't still
accountable but it's accountable in a
broader sense to the legislature and the
governor
so those are kind of just some general
General ways I think about the office I
think about the office that way in large
part based on
um
how AGS throughout the years have
thought about the office how the
legislature throughout the years has
treated the office how the governor's
office has treated the office and how
courts have generally opined on on the
offices function in the office's role so
that's that's sort of in a broad sense
is good context for the various
functions I'm going to talk through
um the next slide which was sort of
client service versus independent
obligations basically that's that's what
I just talked about so in one sense
we're serving a client in another sense
we have sort of independent obligations
to enforce the law and ensure compliance
the rest of this PowerPoint basically
gets to the specifics of what I think I
was asked to talk about today which is
just an overview of the structure of the
office
the PowerPoint roughly tracks the
organizational chart I'm basically going
to go kind of from left to right on the
org chart so whatever is useful to you I
think you can reference but when you
at the top
obviously you've got the senior
leadership of the office you've got the
Attorney General the deputy attorney
general and the chief of staff and then
we also have a director of
communications and a director of
administration that kind of makes up the
what we call the front office in the
Attorney General's office so essentially
the the senior leadership of the office
that that work with all parts of the
office and not just one specific
function
foreign
McGuire has a question sure yeah thank
you and thank you for coming
um I don't see a whole lot of numbers in
here which is kind of our purview when
you're talking about the org chart can
you kind of say how what's the head
count under each group or you know
approximately because that's kind of
where we what we think about yep
absolutely and I could certainly provide
you I can provide I have we have a
presentation that's more detailed which
of course we would plan to give you once
we're presenting our budget but I can
give you a rough sense of it today we
have about 160 to 170 employees total in
roughly 80 to 90 of those positions are
lawyers
and the rest of those positions are
non-lawyer personnel
and as we go through the various areas
of the office I can give you a rough
head count and I will have of course
those exact numbers for you once we've
got got our our budget once your but our
budget is in front of you and we're
the first part of the office is the
division of public protection
and that is kind of exactly how it
sounds and it is the part of the office
that really focuses on on law
enforcement so it has the criminal
justice Bureau it has the consumer
protection antitrust Bureau and it has
the Environmental Protection Bureau
the Environmental Protection Bureau kind
of falls into both camps really it
there's a law enforcement component to
that and there's also a client
counseling component to that but you'll
see that throughout the Department of
Justice
um
given the nature of what we do
some functions of the office don't fall
neatly into one camp or the other some
functions do both civil and criminal
work some functions do both client
counseling and public Protection work
some
functions do litigation and
non-litigation work you know that
they're they're just by nature is is a
mix in a lot of these different
functions but in a rough sense the
division of public protection is mostly
criminal prosecution and law enforcement
type functions
the division of legal counsel is the
other side of the office and that that
does civil litigation
civil client counseling for the state
that has the charitable trust unit which
registers and oversees charities in the
state that has the debt Recovery Unit
which seeks to recover debts that are
owed to the state that can be any type
of debt from unpaid taxes to
um
unfulfilled contract obligations that an
agency might have had with a vendor it
really can cover anything and it's
really up to State agencies throughout
the state to refer things to the debt
Recovery Unit
the division of legal counsel has the
election law unit this is another part
of the office that's unique and that it
does civil and criminal work if someone
sues the state challenging one of the
state's election laws then the election
law unit defends that statute if someone
violates the state selection laws the
election law unit prosecutes that person
for violating the state's election laws
so it's another part of the office that
does kind of both criminal and civil
functions and then the Civil Rights unit
is also in the division of legal counsel
so that's a high level vision of the two
we also have a moving
over to the far right the office of
solicitor general
that handles all appeals within the
office
it does Criminal and Civil Appeals and
it kind of helps guide legal strategy
after that we have the office of the
chief medical examiner
one of the reasons the org chart is in
draft form is because right now it shows
the office of the chief medical examiner
within division of within the division
of public protection it's really not
within that division it's its own
independent entity and it needs to be
because the courts need to be able to
rely on the feedback of the medical
examiner when they're asked to conduct
an autopsy opine on a cause of death
that really they need to be doing that
analysis and answering those questions
independently they're not a tool of the
prosecution they're their own their own
independent independent actor
and then the office has a director of
administration which
does kind of Base it pretty much does
the basic business functions of the
office
under the director of minute of
administration is a director of Law
Office infrastructure
who kind of handles the technology needs
and basic infrastructure needs of the
office we have a business office that's
under the director of administration the
business office uh
performs accounting functions and basic
payroll functions there's a victims
compensation unit in that part of the
office the victim's compensation unit
oversees the state's victims
Compensation Program
state has a program in which victims of
crime can apply to receive I think it's
up to fifty thousand dollars to help
with any costs or expenses that they
might incur because of the fact that
they're a victim of a crime
and then that part of the office also
has the grants management unit and
strategic initiatives we have kind of a
grants management and strategic
initiatives unit that goes out and seeks
grants that might be available for
various law enforcement functions
whether it's from the federal government
or other parties and we often sub-grant
those funds out to to other agencies in
state government local law enforcement
agencies or private organizations in in
some instances
I recognize I am going kind of fast
because there is a lot to talk about
with the office but I will
I I'm going to now get a little bit more
into the weeds and here I'm going to
give you some rough numbers and head
counts I'm going to start on the left
of the org chart in the division of
public protection go through each Bureau
and unit just to give you a sense of how
many people are in each one but happy to
representative thank you
um I just wondered if you could explain
like within each state agency they also
have legal counsel
so what's the interface with the AG's
office yeah that's a great question so
we
some agencies have their own in-house
lawyers and in the AG's office we have
what we call a client counseling unit so
our client counseling unit works and
serves every state agency and state
government
and for agencies that have in-house
attorneys our client counseling unit
Works directly with those attorneys on
the legal needs of those agencies
typically we handle the Overflow so if
there's something
that an agency is was working on that is
too big for their in-house lawyers to
handle we will provide additional
support we also provide legal advice to
those in-house lawyers so on on
complicated questions of law where they
feel like they they can't answer it
themselves they reach out to us and we
interface with them we also proactively
reach out to those lawyers because part
of our job is to make sure that all
agencies are complying with the law and
not doing anything that they're not
supposed to be doing and making sure
that they're doing this the jobs that
the legislature has given them right
they're not missing something so that
that's kind of how that interface goes
it's a it's a good collaboration but
sometimes it's also sort of a form of
supervision because I think
the way the office has always viewed
that relationship is that because the
Attorney General is the chief legal
officer we have a responsibility both to
assist
lawyers and agencies but also ensure
that they're they're getting to the
right legal answers and my experience
has been that eight lawyers and agencies
want that type of collaboration they're
not looking to sort of go Rogue so to
speak they're just looking to do their
jobs well but that that's kind of how we
so I know like with doit they have
embeds in different agencies and then
they charge those agencies for their do
you charge the agencies for your
services yeah there's a couple there's a
couple different ways we quote charge
for our services one and I'm gonna be
honest I am not very well versed in the
whole Das is better at this but there's
there's a whole mechanism by which
um and I forget what it's called but for
for services that are provided Statewide
all agencies sort of pay pay a rough
share of those and legal services is one
of those categories so every agency is
kind of paying their share for Legal
Services
and that's
what was that
yeah and that's that's one way we we
charge agencies another way we charge
agencies is we do have some particular
agencies that have unique legal needs
and in that sense those agencies will
pay for a lawyer within the Department
of Justice to be get dedicated
specifically to them the puc is a great
example we have a lawyer that the puc
pays for and that lawyer is dedicated
specifically to working with the puc
because the puc is kind of a niche area
and they have very unique legal needs so
those are kind of the two ways we charge
all right
so now I'm going to get into
get into the meat of this with the time
that we have
the first Bureau I'm going to talk about
is within the within the division of
public protection and it is the largest
Bureau in the office so it's probably
the bureau that warrants the most
discussion and it's the criminal justice
Bureau
so the criminal justice Bureau had again
it's the largest Bureau in the office it
has roughly 30 to 35 attorneys in it
so
just in one Bureau you have roughly 40
percent of the lawyers in the office but
given the office's core law enforcement
function it makes sense
there are multiple units within the
criminal justice Bureau the biggest unit
is the homicide unit
the homicide unit has probably six to
seven lawyers that are specifically
dedicated to two homicides
but every attorney within the criminal
justice Bureau just about
catches a homicide case from time to
time we do that just to sort of spread
that work out and get everybody
experience doing homicide cases because
homicide cases are our biggest and
highest profile
and at least on the criminal side are
most important cases
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman how many homicides are there in
New Hampshire a year and how many become
charged I mean how many is there a case
as far as a percentage of what you know
how many cases do we solve and bring
charges for in the normal course I don't
have
an exact percentage for you I mean the
vast majority we we identify the
perpetrator pretty quickly and we bring
charges pretty quickly I could go back
and try to figure out what that
percentage looks like I don't have an
exact percentage for you but
I think we have a total
you know we have a total of uh
somewhere in the range of 120 130 cold
cases from you know from from all time
so to speak so
you know given that that's the total
number of cold cases and we have average
roughly 18 to 19 per year we solve the
vast majority of the cases but I can go
back certainly it's a good question get
a percentage for you a rough percentage
so so a a homicide case takes up a half
a year of an attorney's time is that
roughly how it works
because you said let's say you had 15
cases you have seven attorneys right
that something like that yeah yep so uh
one homicide case
depending on
the facts and circumstances can take up
a lot of time but homicide lawyers don't
they they focus on homicides if they
have additional capacity we'll give them
other we'll give them other cases but it
really depends but I can tell you
um
one thing that happens with homicide
cases is homicide layers have to be on
call right so they all they split up on
Call shifts but 24 7.
you know so
every minute of every day we have to
have a homicide team on call because a
homicide can happen anytime
um once a homicide does happen
the lawyers work probably 24 7 for a few
days to do the initial investigation get
a sense of what happened go to the scene
secure the scene
um
do that initial work and then if the
case is complicated if it's not obvious
there's a lot of investigative work that
I would say on average I I wouldn't
necessarily say a homicide case takes up
like six months of time necessarily but
it it can if it's very complicated it
may not take up as much time if
everything's on video when you get a
confession right away right and the
person pleads guilty uh trials
another thing that's important to
remember is that you know a homicide
happens in say the year 2020
there's a lot of investigative work
there's a lot of prep the trial for that
case isn't really happening until 2022.
so if you're a homicide attorney you
have at any given time
you're on call so you could catch a new
case anytime you're prepping cases for
trial that have happened in past years
you're working on the appeal for cases
that are already over where you've
gotten a conviction but the person has
appealed and you it's or you're working
on a habeas corpus petition which can
come even after an appeal is resolved so
it's it's sort of a rolling a a rolling
wave of work in the homicide world just
like it is in any criminal case but
homicide and homicides in particular
because they're so complicated in many
instances and they they go on for a long
time and the work comes in waves and
it's not always predictable when the
work is going to come you might get a
break in the case and that creates a
bunch of work so anyway that's a long
way of answering your question yeah
while we're on homicides am I just
paying more attention to television or
homicides ticking upwards in the state
so we average 18 to 19 per year we I
think we had 29 last year so last year
we were above average we had a big year
in 2019 we had 33.
so in a couple of recent years we've had
above average years and what that does
is it creates a lot of work in that year
but because of what what I just
described it also creates a lot of work
in the years that follow because those
cases are starting to go to trial right
they're they're starting to heat up and
so
the homicide lawyers they're not just
working on the cases that happened
yesterday they're working on they're
working on getting ready for trial on
the next unit we've got is the the drug
unit the drug unit has four
full-time attorneys in it so the drug
unit
basically does our most
our most complicated drug prosecutions
in the state all of the County attorneys
also do drug cases so we do not have
exclusive jurisdiction over drug cases
the way we do over homicides but we tend
to take on the more complicated the more
representative hatch
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question the County Attorney do they
always start with the drug cases or is
it sometimes automatic to State Attorney
General's office handles that or is it
they turn it over to you or how does
that work so we it depends most most of
our drug cases originate with us and
that's because we have the Attorney
General's drug task force the Attorney
General's drug task force which I I was
going to get to it's also part of the
criminal Bureau that is made up of
officers from local law enforcement
agencies around the state those agencies
will send their officers for two or
three years to our drug task force and
that's what we use to investigate more
complicated drug cases or if we become
aware of an operation or a drug ring
that we decide to investigate we'll use
the drug task force and that's kind of
how we originate our more complicated
drug cases the County attorneys don't do
as much of those types of cases they
they do some of them they do some
complicated cases but they do a lot more
of the smaller stuff that doesn't
yep
the next part of the office and I'm I'm
using the slides just for reference so
I'm going a little bit out of the order
of what's on the org chart but I think
it's easy enough to to find each of
these units there but the next part of
the office is the Medicaid fraud control
unit
that unit has three lawyers and that
that unit's job is basically to
prosecute Medicaid fraud so that unit
gets mostly gets referrals from the
Department of Health and Human Services
because if they see something that looks
off they'll make referrals to our
Medicaid fraud control unit and that
unit will investigate and prosecute
Medicaid fraud that unit is interesting
because it is mostly federally funded as
part of the Medicaid Program generally
the state has to have a Medicaid fraud
control unit so every state has one of
these
almost every state has this unit within
their attorney general's office and
we also have in the criminal justice
Bureau Cold Case unit that has two
full-time attorneys and the Cold Case
unit is is dedicated to working on cases
by the very definition that have gone
cold so cases that are difficult to
solve where we've you know we've
followed every immediate lead and and
we're at a I don't like to call it a
dead end because we don't consider any
case a dead end and every case we
continue to work on until we either
solve it or
um
so much time has gone by right that we
know that the perpetrator must be dead
just based on based on math but we we
constantly continue to work cold cases
we have two attorneys that are dedicated
to that work and we have a lot of other
attorneys that do some work on cold
cases but there are two attorneys who
spend their time exclusively on that
work
thank you how successful has that been
can you say for the past five years
you've filed 10 cases or something like
that or
I I don't have exact numbers for you
what I would say is I think we have a
lot of room to improve and how we work
cold cases in this state and I think
we've we've seen some starts and stops
on really getting the Cold Case unit
going a few years ago there was a lot of
talk about dedicating two lawyers to the
Cold Case unit that didn't happen right
away because of covid
um and it kind of went by the wayside
for a while
since I've been in office and as we've
come out of the pandemic we're
rededicating ourselves to the Cold Case
unit so the best way to answer your
question there representative is that I
think we have we have a lot of work to
do to get where I think we need to be I
every lawyer in the office is dedicated
and does great work works very hard but
I think we
especially in the rural communities in
this state
cold cases are important and and being
someone who is from you know from the
upper valleys from a community outside
the Manchester Nashua area these cases
have a real impact on their communities
when they happen so anyway so long
answer your question again but we've got
the criminal Bureau also has the office
of victim witness assistance
this office
has victim Advocates we've got four
victim Advocates and they work with
families
they work with victims they work with
Witnesses who are part of our case is to
basically get them what they need
support them not only during an
investigation and during a trial but
also afterwards when someone's the
victim of a crime and particularly when
someone's a victim of a serious crime
it's it's a life-changing event and
there are a lot of things that flow from
that Beyond just finding the perpetrator
and Prosecuting them you know can upend
their entire lives so our office of
victim witness assistance is sort of
dedicated to serving those victims and
their families and also serving
Witnesses often the Witnesses are also
victims right and often the most
important Witnesses are the victims of
the crime but that's where that office
is dedicated to that office also does
the drug task force like I mentioned is
also part of the criminal justice Bureau
for the most part the drug task force
is not comprised of employees of the
Department of Justice it's comprised
mostly of officers from local
departments either Sheriff's departments
or local police departments that are on
loan from those agencies we do have a
commander and a deputy commander of the
drug task force and those are full-time
employees of of the Attorney General's
office
foreign
I should say the criminal justice Bureau
also has a public Integrity unit
the public Integrity unit is dedicated
to Prosecuting crimes committed by state
officials law enforcement officials and
other other public officials we focus
mostly on either State officials or
members of law enforcement but we will
also take cases
um
that involve Municipal officials County
officials just depending on the
circumstance and depending on how
and then the last part the criminal
justice Bureau that we have right now
which is a temporary part of the office
but right now a very important part of
the office is is the YDC unit so that
unit is is focused on Prosecuting the
um
or investigating I should say
allegations of sexual abuse and physical
abuse at the former YDC and prosecute
Prosecuting the perpetrators of of those
crimes
that unit is
we have a couple attorneys who are
dedicated solely to doing that but we
have also spread that work throughout
the criminal justice Bureau because of
the volume because of the number of
folks who have come forward and frankly
just because those cases are difficult
and it is it's hard for any one person
to spend their whole day doing just that
as as hardened as our attorneys are and
as much as they've seen those types of
representative McGuire thank you have
there been any successful conclusions to
cases in this area
no I mean well I should say we we have
charged 11 people
um for acts against I think it's 21
victims we're still waiting for those
cases to go to trial the first try the
first trials were scheduled to begin
this year they've been pushed back given
the the volume of documents involved in
those trials and also I think given some
of the struggles with the public
defender program but those trials are
still scheduled to take place but no
trials have taken place yet so we are
gearing up we're doing everything we can
to be ready but we are at the mercy of
the Court's calendar and of document
production and the public defender being
ready
representative hatch thank you Mr chair
just
um recent events at the uh sununu Center
um numbers that were initially presented
to us were a lot more than what you're
saying now so
um is there a plethora of these pending
or or what what's happening with that or
what do we need to be prepared for
Budget wide says my my concern yeah it's
a good question so on the criminal side
with YDC
and I've had the chance to speak about
this a lot as I think many of you
remember
many many of
the allegations we get and
um the victims who are coming forward
are cases that really aren't cases will
ever be able to prosecute because
they're beyond the statute of
limitations we still try to at least
talk to those victims but you know on
from the criminal side it's going to be
only a small fraction of of the
allegations that we can ever prosecute
for partly because of the statute of
limitations partly because these are
just very old cases and building a case
that you can prove Beyond Reasonable
Doubt is is already hard in sexual
assault cases it's especially hard when
they're very old so on the criminal side
I think I think we have we have a handle
on it I think we we have been able to
spread the cases out throughout the
office and I think we have the resources
we need and we come for the litigation
fund when we need it the Civil side's a
little a little different yeah yeah
representative evil
it's a little out of order but just
before you leave this page on the
Medicaid fraud control unit are those
individuals or Corp or doctors offices
or who do you tend to see in that
situation yeah in my experience it's
it's individuals so not doctors offices
but someone who says that they
um got rides to and from a doctor's
office they need reimbursement for but
they never got the rides or they were
getting treatment that they sought
reimbursement for they just never
actually got that got that treatment so
my experience has been we we see mostly
individuals I think there is probably
more work we can do to try to identify
whether there's any more white collar
fraud going on in either doctor's
offices or other health care practices
but that's not typically what we've seen
in my time in the office
then just one other question on the cold
cases have you seen the number of cold
cases
over time or has the office I mean
I just wonder if they're building up or
what the
my as I said earlier my senses we have
we have a way we have some improvement
to make and how we handle cold cases but
I I can't tell you from a numbers
perspective whether we've kind of stayed
flat or whether they just keep building
the other two bureaus in the division of
public protection are the consumer
protection and antitrust Bureau and the
Environmental Protection Bureau the
consumer protection and antitrust Bureau
really does three basic things it does
Consumer Protection work
so a great example that we see a lot are
contractors who you know you hire
someone to do a renovation on your house
they take a check for fifty thousand
dollars they never do the work
our office does those cases and we're
kind of the one agency in the state that
prosecutes those cases we're unique
throughout in the country in having
criminal jurisdiction over those cases a
lot of times those cases are handled
civilly we actually have the ability to
to prosecute those cases criminally
which is effective it's it's a hammer
and I think a good a good deterrent but
that that's part of what that Bureau
does just the basic Consumer Protection
work
the bureau also does Anti-Trust work
so the Anti-Trust unit within the bureau
reviews and I'm sure you've seen
prominent examples of this reviews
mergers between health care companies to
see whether there are antitrust concerns
it sort of monitors the marketplace to
see whether anyone is engaging in
anti-competitive conduct or violating
the state's Anti-Trust laws we mostly
see
transaction based issues that's that's
when we tend to see antitrust issues
when a merger's taking place we don't
encounter as much what I call conduct
based issues so a company is not merging
with another they're just engaging in
anti-competitive conduct we don't see as
much of that
and then that that Bureau also has the
elder abuse and financial exploitation
unit
um I know I'll be talking to you about
this
during our sort of core budget
presentation but that is a growing area
for the state and that's that's an area
that really could use more resources
we're having discussions with the
governor's office on that front now and
I'm sure we'll have those same
discussions with you all once once the
budget
lands on your plate in a couple weeks
but that is a um that is a very
important part of the office I think
within the Consumer Protection Bureau
and it's a it's a growing area that I
think the state needs to focus on
okay
oh absolutely well you said we'll be
talking more about it but to what do you
attribute the increases in this so
there are a number of factors but the
two factors that I think are contribute
the most to the increase in this are one
we're an aging state right I think we we
all know that but two I think the
the
um
the gains and technology that we've seen
over the last 20 years sort of the
exponential
um enhancements in technology
have opened up a lot of opportunities
for fraud and I think what you what you
see is a lot of individuals who who they
get to an advanced age they may not have
been familiar with some of these new
technologies and
it it's
if they've never interacted with with
technology they are more susceptible to
sort of scams over the Internet even
scam scams over the phone
um
scams even just through paper that are
generated through through uh
technological
technological scam so just form letters
that are just wrong websites that are
fake
um fake places to go do your taxes right
oh go to this website you'll you'll get
a tax refund just give me your social
security number and all that they're
just all sorts of new new opportunities
for scamming people over the internet
and through technology and I think that
combined with an aging population has
has contributed to to a real rise in in
fraud against the elderly I also think
that the pandemic the covid-19 pandemic
has contributed to a rise in this over
the last couple of years because when
people are isolated they're more
they're more vulnerable to that type of
that type of scam and it
the final factor I would say that's
important is it's just kind of a human
factor I think
someone who gets older
you know maybe your spouse has died your
kids live far away you're just we just
see people when they don't have social
interaction more susceptible to to
someone just calling them up over the
phone and befriending them and
engaging in some type of scam so
those are the reasons
it's always been there but I think it's
gotten worse
so are you looking for more staff there
that's what I might take away or yeah do
you have a specific number that you're
looking at or
yeah we we have requested an additional
lawyer an additional paralegal and
additional investigator right now that
unit it's a fairly new unit it only has
one dedicated lawyer and no dedicated
investigator or paralegal so there
there is a lot of room for growth there
I never think it's a good idea to grow
any particular unit too fast because you
have to sort of
really see how much how much work there
is to do but but that's what we've
requested in the governor's budget
process and that's what I anticipate
that's what will be before you because I
I don't want to speak for the governor
or get out ahead of him but I I am
fairly optimistic that that will make it
into his budget but those are the
numbers a new attorney a new
investigator and a new apparently and a
new paralegal
sounds like a very good idea to me yeah
and while we're on it I just want to
thank your charitable trust group
thought they did an amazing job with the
granite one Dartmouth merger and just
want to thank they did very thorough
work and absolutely appreciate it so yes
and our antitrust unit was working on
that too so I just want to give them a
shout out thanks yeah
do you have anything else representative
McGuire I see a few questions here on
your sheep he lets me know he writes
them ahead of time so he checked them
off
well we're running low at times yeah so
keep going yeah I was just if it was
anything pressing on your list there
okay
we'll continue then yeah the
Environmental Protection Bureau is
pretty straightforward so I won't spend
a ton of time there basically
we bring environmental enforcement
actions in that Bureau and we also we
provide client counseling services to
the Department of Environmental Services
that's what the Environmental Protection
Bureau does it has five lawyers and and
some staff but that that Bureau uh
basically serves Des it also works with
I'm now sort of moving over to the
division of legal counsel that's more
the Civil side of the office
within the division of legal counsel we
have the civil litigation unit and the
client counseling unit and those two
things make up what we call the Civil
Bureau so the civil litigation unit does
exactly what it sounds like it does it
defends the state state agencies
employees State officials in litigation
that's brought against them so we have
um that unit there is a lot of work in
that unit right now the state is dealing
with a lot of major cases a lot of major
litigation we have I think we have the
resources appropriated to it necessary
that's a unit within the office and
we're seeing this in a lot of places in
state government where we just have
Workforce challenges
civil litigators are particularly hard
to hire in state service because unlike
prosecutors where if you want to be a
prosecutor the Attorney General's office
is the best place to be in the state
as a civil litigator I think you get to
do really cool work I think it's really
fulfilling work but you can make a lot
of money in private practice you don't
make you know you can't be a prosecutor
in private practice right if you want to
be a prosecutor you got to come work in
public service if you want to be a civil
litigator you can work in the private
sector and make a lot more money so I
think we have great lawyers who are
handling the work we're getting done
what we need to get done but the
workforce to the extent we have
Workforce challenges in the Department
of Justice the civil litigation unit is
our biggest challenge and you see that I
know representative leishman sees that
when we come to fiscal for money in the
litigation fund because when we're down
lawyers we have to get some assistance
from outside counsel and that's when we
come to the litigation fund
the client counseling unit is is also
they they're civil attorneys they they
work with state agencies they to
representative Abel's question earlier
they interface with the lawyers who are
in state agencies
their goal really is to keep the state
out of court so to make sure everyone's
complying with the law staying in their
Lane doing what they need to do so that
we don't end up in litigation it's
really what the client counseling unit
does
within the division of legal counsel we
also have the transportation and
construction Bureau it's kind of a
deceptively named Bureau because it
works with the Department of
Transportation but it also works with
the Department of Safety
so that Bureau is unique because it is
mostly funded by Highway funds and it
works pretty much exclusively with only
two agencies the Department of
Transportation and the Department of
Safety but given that dot and the
department of safety are two of the
biggest agencies in state government it
it certainly provides enough work for
one Bureau it's a pretty small Bureau
the charitable trust unit is the primary
regulator of charities in the state in
that in that unit we we register
Charities we oversee Charities and
ensure they're they're complying with
their obligations and we do that by
getting annual filings that Charities
have to make each year so we're both
monitoring to make sure Charities are
filing what they're supposed to file and
we're reviewing those filings to ensure
and then we also have the debt Recovery
Unit
the debt Recovery Unit does again kind
of exactly what it sounds like it does
it it attempts to recover debts that are
owed to the state and as I mentioned
earlier that that can be anywhere from
unpaid taxes from long long ago because
the Department of Revenue Administration
will handle recently unpaid tax bills
but if we discover taxes that have long
gone unpaid might get referred to our
debt Recovery Unit if there's a we had a
contract with a vendor the state had a
contract with a vendor and they didn't
perform work or they owe us money we may
go after that vendor through the debt
Recovery Unit
that unit is small it only has one
lawyer there is
probably more work the state could do
there we have not done a full analysis
of that but I just mentioned that given
this committee's role in the legislature
making sure that we're recovering all
debt so to the state is probably an area
that that we could we could use some
growth in and we could explore ways to
recover monies owed to the state
representative Griffin do you have an
idea of the magnitude of the recoveries
from that unit
I don't but that's information I could
representative evil thank you
it's kind of what
because I'd be interested in a return on
investment like if you had more staff do
you think you could really
yep bring in a lot more
yeah I think what would be worth doing
on that front is uh
is an analysis or a study on that you
know as I mentioned that that's just
something I've observed we have not and
I don't think the office has at any time
in recent memory done a full analysis of
that like if we had another lawyer if we
had these resources
how much out there is there owed to the
state that could be recovered so I think
it's a it's a project worth undertaking
the other two components of the division
of legal counsel are the election law
unit and the Civil Rights unit
um so again these are
what these units do is kind of explained
by their titles but the election law
unit both
um prosecutes violations of the state's
election laws it works with the
secretary of state to ensure that our
elections are run well and they're run
in compliance with the law
every election day we send attorneys
from the office out to just about every
polling place in the state they they
rotate around the state they travel all
around the state and we cover we cover
pretty much every polling place and the
goal is to make sure we're assisting
local election officials but that we're
also not far away if an issue comes up
and and there's a dispute on site about
what someone's allowed to do or
um what an election official should or
shouldn't be doing
um that unit also works with
municipalities so it works with local
election officials leading up to
elections on training
um on Election law compliance and just
on basic tips for how to run an
efficient election as you can imagine
that the needs of various polling places
vary a lot you know Manchester is a lot
different than our small towns in the
North country and the election law unit
works with the secretary of state to try
to fill those gaps where there may not
be as many resources in the municipality
itself
the Civil Rights unit again sort of
similar to the election law unit it
enforces the state civil rights laws we
also try to do some work on on the
training front so we try to put out
information for law enforcement on how
to spot civil rights violations we try
to make information available to
businesses so so they have an idea of
what they need to comply with and that
unit works a lot with the Human Rights
Commission
again we already kind of covered the
office of solicitor general but I'll
just hit it again here briefly that
office it's really two major functions
are to oversee all of the appeals but
then the Attorney General's office so
both Criminal Appeals and Civil Appeals
and also to kind of guide legal strategy
so I get the solicitor general and his
staff involved in major litigation that
we anticipate is going to result in an
appeal so when we know we have a big
case that we that we are litigating at
the trial court level but that we
anticipate is going to go up to the
state supreme court or go up on appeal
through the federal system we try to
anticipate the major issues right from
the start knowing that we're going to be
fighting it out on appeal no matter what
happens whether we win or lose we're
appealing so that's really the role of
the office of solicitor general it's
still a fairly new office in our
department of justice the solicitor
general position was just created I
think back in 2018 in this state but I
think it's a very very good function for
us to have
foreign
and then I talked about it earlier but
I'll just hit it again briefly the
office of the chief medical examiner it
doesn't really fit into either sort of
the division of public protection or the
division of legal counsel because it's
its own independent entity but the
office of the chief medical examiner
performs death investigations and
performs autopsies and it also does a
lot of work to coordinate a collection
and production of data related to deaths
in the state so overdose deaths for
instance when you see that data that
really comes out of the office of the of
the chief medical examiner because
they're seeing all the deaths they're
collecting the causes of death they're
seeing the toxicology reports so they're
in the best position to collect and
and then the final piece of the office
of like any office we we have just basic
Administration functions that don't deal
with core substantive legal issues but
really just help us run run the office
and and seek grant funding so that's the
director of of administration again that
has the director of Law Office
infrastructure so the person who
basically oversees the the technology
and infrastructure needs of the office
that
division of the office has the business
office which just handles payroll and
accounting services
that division has the victim's
compensation unit which works to take in
applications and pay out compensation to
victims of crime and then that division
has the grants management and strategic
initiatives unit and the grants
management unit again I mentioned it
earlier but its job is really to to seek
out opportunities to bring grant funding
in into the state both for the
Department of Justice itself for state
agencies for local agencies and for
private organizations like for instance
the Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence
so that that is an overview of the
functions of the Attorney General's
office to representative McGuire's
question I didn't bring specific head
counts and numbers because I I thought I
my understanding was this was more just
to give you a sense of what we do but we
will certainly have all of that ready
for you as you enter the budget process
and when we come for our budget
presentation I will make sure you have
that information I'll make sure to get
that information to you in advance and I
think you're going to get that as part
of the budget I mean my having spent too
much time with the budget I worked on
three governors budgets in my time when
I was with the governor I know that in
the section for each agency it gives you
a great breakdown of of headcount but
we'll make sure we have that information
for you when you're when you've got the
you'll find the Attorney General's
budget is quite detailed and doing a
great job you've stepped into the shoes
of a number of people in the past and
you're a credit to the agency from my
experience so thank you I appreciate it
just speaking for myself but that's been
my experience I appreciate that thank
you Mr chair representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman yeah I'm
particularly impressed by the size of
your entourage here because
[Laughter]
we often see you know two three Etc but
that to me is a sign of good deficiency
anyway yeah
um we are in a fish in office I do
believe we are not over resourced in any
way
um let me ask specifically is your
office ever on both sides of a case if
we have like a whistleblower who figures
out some agency is doing something wrong
are you defending that agency and
Prosecuting it that is such a timely
question I mean I mean the answer is yes
right so YDC is a good example you know
technically in YDC we're not on both
sides of the case because we're we're
Prosecuting the individual perpetrators
right we are defending the agency so
we're not defending the individuals
we're defending the agency to the extent
their allegations that the agency was
negligent in supervising the the former
YDC workers but yeah we are we are at at
least to the public on both sides in
that case we also have cases where
you know we represent the puc
we represent the department of energy
we represent the consumer Advocate right
so
um the puc May issue a decision that
gets appealed
the consumer Advocate may want to take
one position on that appeal so we're
representing the puc on appeal somebody
else is in the office is representing
the consumer Advocate and then the
department of energy may have a position
in that and so someone else in the
office is representing the department of
energy
we have procedures that have been in
place in the office for a long time
where we put up walls in those cases so
we make sure that those lawyers are not
talking to each other they know nothing
about what the other lawyers are doing
it's a big enough office that we can do
that but we do have instances like that
where we're on the opposite side of a
case
seeing no further question again thanks
very much and we'll see you in a couple
of weeks absolutely you can bring
Catherine next time too yeah yeah cat I
think Kathy Carr will be here when we
get into the real budget weeds that's
for sure
foreign
all right uh being just a few minutes
after one Charlie time
um
we have some amendments at the
representative evil would like to ask
the LBA to pass out on
so the Amendments you're about to
receive is someone of the result of
most the work being done by
representative evil over the weekend
working with some of us Charlie
arlinghaus has been very helpful
in this process and while we're taking a
look at the language is uh Charlie would
you like to come forward and
give
if you have hard questions I have with
me uh Karen ransomaki and Ted kupper who
are smarter than I am but um we so we we
talked um
representative evil had you know
concerns about oversight and and
obviously we want oversight and we I
actually like the idea of renaming the
capital budget committee to the capital
projects committee because it's it's not
about source of funding it's about type
of project and uh
you know we're always happy we're always
happier when somebody's looking over our
shoulders so to speak because it's it's
the way things are meant to be so so I
like the idea of doing this and I think
the I think the the amendment and and I
think I saw the final draft of it or
something pretty close to it
um I think it does a good job of
basically doing that and saying for this
particular project we should have a uh a
more formalized uh oversight committee
with multiple people on it and I I think
that'll be very useful because it's um
my understanding is that there's great
interest in the legislature as a whole
about this particular construction
project and so we would like to
suck up to that so to speak
well well said as it was stated when you
were here last time you know I'm
speaking for myself but thinking I'm
speaking for everybody we have a great
deal of respect for you and how you
handle the steam project and other
projects and believe you're very much
involvement with your folks is necessary
and uh
I think this cleans things up a little
bit it makes it very clear it allows for
a public member to be appointed I did
speak to
several people of the weekend including
Senate President Bradley uh former
Senate President Morse
who I've said publicly I guess that I'd
like to see involved in this group
because of his expertise and
um someone I greatly respect so
hopefully all of you have had a chance
to look at this or if
representative evil would like to add
um thank you Mr chairman so just as a
general matter I've had an ongoing
concern about capital
projects that are coming through our
legislature that uh
if they if if they're generally funded
they come through the finance committee
if their capital budget item they come
through the public works and in public
works there's a real sort of clear
pathway for oversight but for for a
capital budget items but for some reason
there's not a similar mechanism for
things that come through finance things
that are financed through arpa funds I
mean there's a whole host of capital
projects where the whole oversight
mechanism is a little fuzzy and so
um
I also think that the legislative
parking garage which is a 25 million
dollar item is a huge project and the
oversight was a little fuzzy there too
so I thought
um for after discussions with various
people
um I worked to put together this
amendment which was basically make the
capital budget overview committee the
capital project overview committee and
I've just basically replaced the word
budget with project
but as the chairman indicated there's a
special
sense of of the structure that we would
need for the legislative parking garage
oversight and so we put together this
commission which tracks a little bit
like the capital budget over
site committee but with a couple of
tweaks it does allow the appointment at
the option of the president of the
Senate and the speaker of the house to
to appoint public members
um we do have the commissioner of Das or
designee on there and we do have the
chairman of house Public Works
on there and house finance or their
designees and so that pulls in the
capital committee which is public works
it pulls in finance which is the source
of the general funds and it also has
other legislators that are involved
um
I mean that's the upshot of it the other
thing is it makes it really clear that
the legislative members are there for
their term but the public members can
stay in place until they're replaced or
upon completion of the project and then
it it sets up sort of a six-month
overview
um
calendar for the legislative parking
garage oversight commission but they're
also going to be providing information
to the capital project overview
committee so that's the upshot and I
I mean I think the main idea here
when you have such an expensive project
you're concerned about having a very
clear line as to procedures and you want
to have the oversight
um and transparency
I just felt like this is the way to go
Mr chairman if I could just add on that
which would I think was very well put
um I think that
um
leaving aside the garage itself one of
the things that that this does is in you
know back in the day it was unusual to
have capital projects that weren't
funded for the capital budget that's
just where they went and that's why the
law is constructed the way it was in
recent years we've had some you know
some weird stuff going on where
um we've had a whole bunch of them that
you know it used to be that if you had a
capital project that wasn't through the
capital budget was really unusual and
some sort of one-off and but you know we
had arpa and there have been some of
these these Surplus things in
Centerville or Hospital 2 Appropriations
and all of that and I think uh I don't
think anyone would argue that the intent
uh going back to the formation of that
committee whenever that was
um was to oversee projects of this type
not just projects that happen to be in
House Bill 25 they didn't mean to
exclude projects that happened to be in
House Bill too so I think it's a I think
it's a nice thing and it's not frankly
revolutionary so it's just a just good
oversight government
very glad to have your involvement uh so
we're speaking specifically to Amendment
zero three eight four h you see there's
another amendment which will be taken up
separately as far as the funding so
we'll speak to that later is there any
more discussion yes representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman
um so the beginning part here
um about the capital budget now project
overview committee is that strictly a
name change and and doesn't really have
much to do with the parking garage
it's strictly a name change
okay and and so you
um decided not to make the parking
garage thing like a subcommittee of that
committee you you created a brand new
one is that right
there was there was conversation about
that uh original drafts that I
circulated I did have it as a
subdivision of the capital budget
overview Committee in fact one idea that
I had was just to add a couple of
capital uh a couple of public members to
that committee to act as the oversight
but there's so many folks on that
committee it seemed unwieldy and there
was a lot of interest in um
ensuring that uh the Das
representative beyond the legislative
parking garage oversight commission so
that's what is put together here it's a
smaller group of people
um and people that have a real interest
in this project
blame me if you don't like that part of
it no that's fine I I don't really have
an objection to this but I just let you
know that just this morning in the
chairs meeting the speaker and the clerk
told us don't start anymore commissions
committees Etc and if you do you'll be
on it so I hope you'll I hope you are
prepared
hahaha
um yeah I mean I I 100
appreciate that uh view I mean I hold
that view myself but I think this is a
very
I know other people might argue the same
about their commissions I think this is
a particular uh
um situation where we need oversight of
this type by the legislature and I would
like to think that the Senate President
and the speaker would
um applaud this
commission's creation
thank you
um just about the powers of this
committee right or commission
um it looks like they have the power to
say no to a change in the plans but not
a power to create a change of plans is
so what what I would say is that's the
way it is with the capital budget
overview committee too it's an oversight
Authority I think that's what's true
with most oversight authorities I think
if they wanted to pursue a change there
might have to be some other mechanism
I'm not familiar and I mean I don't know
how it would work with public works or I
mean maybe the commissioner could help
with I think
um
I I think that's not that unusual in in
so the way that you know a project is
designed there are project managers
their Architects Etc I'm more involved
in the committee and and there are
regular meetings
um
I think one of the things you want to
avoid is the is the point where you have
a committee of Architects
um you know buildings designed by a
committee as opposed to an architect
whose designs have been approved by a
committee and I think the you know the
language and I forget the exact wording
of it which is um
you know no change shall be made
no change shall be made so um without
their approval what we're what we're
really talking about doing is we're
going to hire an architect
and and that architect with with
Consultants is not literally one guy
sitting at a big desk but um it's going
to design the building
and you know there'll be input what what
typically happens on any project is
there's input but uh there's a there's a
project manager at um at Public Works in
this case it'll be an architect
um uh named Keith Hemingway I think it's
Keith right yeah so there's uh and so
they'll go through that and then and
then this Committee in an early stage
would be involved at looking at those
plans but not sitting down and
discussing the the details and at that
point there's a design you finalize the
committee will have signed off on it and
then and then the thought is we won't
make any changes we'll probably have a
discussion at the beginning of the
committee about
about you know level right the you know
minor change orders versus major change
orders because projects have lots and
lots of change orders
um and decided what what accounts for
that but what you what you don't want to
have as a as a you know committee who's
was designing it themselves if you know
I'm looking at uh section five repeal
and section six perspective repeal and
section seven effective date
and how do those three sections fit
together
sure that the that the commission that
we would be creating goes away when the
project is over
um and I would say that the creation of
the commission or the requirement that
the commission be created be effective
immediately because the project is
already uh on its way and we need
oversight
no not a problem rip
representative Griffin I would just say
that OLS has been over this and I'm sure
the way they've structured it would work
I think I can clarify just briefly the
the effective date Partners means the
bill is effective and then the repeal
um basically just says that when when
the garage is done and we say it's done
everything goes away
and that this isn't one of those things
that exists in perpetuity so that you
know in 2046 somebody goes what's that
about
thank you that's the way I read it but I
wanted to make sure that
representative evil well and and to
representative
um
I drank a blank Maguire's point about
the uh speaker not loving commissions
that's one of the big problems with
commissions is that they live on in
perpetuity and this one will have a very
uh representative evil I think you
served on a committee right to get rid
of committees and commissions so you
have some knowledge of that yes Mr chair
for two years I I chaired the committee
on committees and um we reviewed every
single statutory committee that existed
which was many and one of we repealed
many but one of our great concerns was
they'd be very clearly structured with a
clear responsibility and a clear
termination date and a clear reporting
scenario to make them as worthwhile as
they could be
thank you representative Hewitt did I
hear you
I I'm just confused about something uh I
know that the top of page two uh appears
that
um
I want to say 17 J5 is established the
joint legislative parking garage
oversight commission and then it looks
like uh in section five uh RSA 17 J5 is
repealed it it almost looks like to the
uneducated that the same statute
establishes and repeals a commission I
can I can address that uh um it does
look that way but if you look at the
effective date
um line four of Page Three section five
of this actual take effect as provided
in section six of this act section
section six is The Language by which
section 5 would take effect and so
Section 5 only takes effect basically
upon me telling you the garage is done
oh
it's
a little bit
you know convoluted but it's I'm I I'm
told it's quite legally sound well and
it's quite ordinary for the legislature
further questions comments of uh the
commissioner or general questions the
only thing I would add is that is that
one of the very smart Karen's in the
room there appear to be lots of them
today
um said uh uh said to me who determines
which projects go before the capital
project overview committee and I I do
think that it's not you know capital
budget overview if it's in the capital
budget and I think that's not entirely
clear from this and it may there's maybe
some in the legislature who who wonder
about that I think that we have other
Provisions in the law you know the
statutes of 21i which determine what's a
what's a project I think it's 21 I-78
but our statutes are evolving around
Public Works and plant and property
which I think would cover that and I
think it's also one of those things and
they either Beholder of the capital
projects committee think it's covered
then it is covered but I just alert you
to that
thank you uh I hope that the
Commissioners proved to all of you why
we need him involved
representative hatch thank you just just
uh from that statement
um
we often do things that involve an
enormous amount of money that might be
captured under this or may not for
example when we did the computer system
that was an enormous amount of money
that was a long-term project and
um who has oversight over that or could
that be captured under this it's I I
don't see specific it's specific for
each well that goes to my point this is
specific for each type of
the parking garage and that's it so when
that's done this is done
nice to see my former boss sitting in
see no further questions uh we can
um I would like to introduce
2023-0384h which would
um
create a legislative
parking garage oversight commission as
we've discussed and also
replace the words budget for the capital
budget overview committee with the word
project so that it does have overview or
oversight Authority for all capital
projects and not just those that come
through the capital budget
ought to pass
it's been moved and
so I'll second this amendment
thank you
the motion's been made in second it is
there any further discussion
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
please call the roll okay this is where
Amendment
2023384h on House Bill three four FNA if
you're in favor if you've stayed gay if
you opposed you say nay representative
McGuire yeah
Griffin representative yes
Clerk voltier
representative Hewitt yay
representative evil yay
and chair Alicia yes
well
eight to nothing the motion passes for
uh Amendment
202-3384. thank you Mr House Bill 384.
thank you Mr clerk thank you
representative Ebel and commissioner for
your work over the weekend
uh
so representative evil you have another
amendment which I believe is zero three
seven two H which talks about the
funding source so a slight change in
what was in the bill you know what from
to speak to your Amendment okay
um
so the other amendment that I have uh
changes uh
the not just the funding source there's
a slight change to that but also it
changes
to whom the money for the parking garage
goes the original
structure of the bill was that the
funding for the parking garage go to the
legislative branch and
um after discussing things here within
the division and and with various other
people
um
this proposal would direct the funding
to go to the Department of
administrative services
and part of the rationale is similar to
the rationale that we had for the
oversight commission and that is that if
you run a capital project of this size
25 million dollars through Das there's a
very bright line as to procedures how it
moves forward they have staff that are
involved with all aspects of a capital
project of this magnitude and
the feeling was that to achieve the
bright line to achieve the degree of
transparency we would have through Das
and the oversight it would be better to
put the money directly in the
Department's
control and then the other rationale is
that actually Das is going to be
responsible for this building after it's
constructed and so it should be as
involved as it can be in the in the
construction
the second aspect of this is that
um it seemed appropriate since this is
really a a project that would benefit
the legislative branch and recognizing
that we have limited general fund
dollars and that there's 10 million
dollars in the legislative account that
2.5 million of the construction costs
should come out of the legislative
account
so it would be 22.5
General funds and 2.5 million out of the
legislative account
and the only other thing I would say is
that the um
the stairs for the lob uh they were paid
for through the legislative account so
thanks for your explanation go ahead
one other thing
um HB 1661 which appropriated the 9.3
million dollars for
um the just the all the planning for the
garage
um and um and related issues that money
went to das
so this is keeping with what that bill
established as far as the where the
funding goes
thank you very much any questions for
seeing none of you prepared to offer
emotion
um oh I'm sorry representative Maguire I
had a question but not for
representative oh
I see Mr faff in the room so I'm
wondering if he would like to comment on
the two aspects of this amendment one
moving it to administrative services and
the other whether this account has
sufficient funds for this purpose
uh thank you Mr chairman for the record
my name is Terry Poff CEO for the
general court
um I think there's sufficient funds
available it does take a vote uh
generally the process is to take a vote
from the facilities committee the
facilities committees established to
oversee already the legislative
facilities and make sure that they're
taken care of and and
represent the legislature the general
Court's interest in those facilities so
there are sufficient funds there we'll
take a vote of the committee how they
want to dice it up to to
um
give the money to the as it's
statutorily going to be required to do
but they it's an easy process there
within the facilities committee to do
that and as far as the Das the goal of
the general Court's always been to get
that garage replaced and so whatever the
process you come up with is fine that's
as long as the goal gets accomplished
currently the existing one is causing
problems right now the netting's
actually getting caught by tractor
trailers that happened again this
morning so we have a crew right down
there now both gcnh personnel and Public
Works personnel and I believe the
contractor trying to repair that so this
is an urgent situation as you all well
know so however we get it passed to
process is what we're a common goal is
going to be achieved and with this um
oversight committee Public Works
involvement I'm a former member of
Public Works when I served here Public
Works involvement's not a bad thing it's
a good thing so I think having
legislative oversight of this
legislative facility is key so having
that input from the legislators you
elected legislators and any staff
backing you might need the general court
is going to be the general court staff
thank you Terry for your comments
nice to see you Mr chairman back there
uh
seeing no additional comments uh
representative evil
for the record I'm sorry Ms I just want
to add that I did look at the
legislative account and there's
approximately 10 million dollars in that
account and it's divided there's a house
account a senate account a joint account
and an LBA account and then when you go
to facilities if we do this facilities
would decide
out of what accounts that money would
come
okay good to have someone here that was
on public works and facilities and yeah
yeah okay
2023-0372h which would appropriate the
money for the legislative parking garage
to the Department of administrative
Services
22.5 million of which would be generally
funded and 2.5 million of which would
come from the special legislative
account
ought to pass do I see a second second
representative McGuire thank you
seeing no discussion on the motion I'd
ask the clerk to please call the roll
okay
202-30372h on House Bill 384 FMA
if you're in favor you will vote yay if
you're opposed you'll vote nay
representative McGuire aye
Griffin representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Cambridge
yes
Clerk voltier
representative Hewitt yes
representative evil yes
and chair leashman yes
well
being 8-0 the motion passes
Jason I'd like to
take a motion to uh
move the bill along as amended so a
Mr chair I'd like to move ought to pass
on HB 384 which is the bill that would
um
build at last our legislative parking
garage I think we've discussed it at
Great length we certainly have the need
and now I feel like with these
amendments we have appropriate oversight
and the funding going to the correct
place so I'd recommend passage thank you
is there a second a second motion
it's been moved and seconded when the
clerk is ready would you please call the
roll
this is
um for House Bill 384 FMA as amended by
2023372h and 2023384-h
we aim for
being in favor of and named for opposing
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Cambridge yes
work votes yes representative Hewitt yay
representative evil yes
we'll be in seven years one day the
motion succeeds
all right thank you all very much I
appreciate all of your efforts
look forward to seeing you in the future
Charlie
so we'll just take
we'll just take a brief five minute
recess everyone and get
it's a little break
I know but we're taking a little break
you know I mean yeah it's I'm shooting
goodbye
so we'll reconvene the work session on
House Bill 506 FNA
the full finance committee heard this on
the first I mean the 22nd of January
and then we heard it again at a work
and with all these work sessions there's
no requirement to have any public
participation but I've always been known
to be pretty liberal so uh
hopefully we can continue that practice
I'm just looking for the
sponsored I know he wanted to have a few
words there he is the representative
from dairy you're welcome to
representative Pearson for those of you
for the record Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District 13 which
um I'd like to begin I was asked by the
chairman of derry's Town Council to read
something to you he uh
so I that's okay I will do so in your
your um your guys got a copy of that as
well and I'll give him this copy too
uh two two excuse me to whom it may
concern my name is Josh Borden I'm
currently serving in my ninth year as
dairy Town Council at large I represent
33 000 people and hold the position of
chairman
I wish I could be there today but I was
unable to move my teaching schedule
junior hockey practice and need to
prepare for tonight's council meeting
for the second time I need to clarify
the council's position regarding our
last vote but first the history prior to
the council voting on The Rail Trail
tunnel I called for a meeting with our
town manager Vice chair representative
Pearson and members of The Dot
I asked the dot two main questions one
if the council decided to vote for the
tunnel would Dairy be on the hook
and two if the council decided to vote
for the tunnel would there be delays and
how long
we were assured by the D.O.T that we
would not be on the hook for additional
spending if we voted for the tunnel and
could expect six months to one year of
delays
have you have you asked the dot if the
above is true question mark
so with this info I put this on the
agenda to be decided one month later at
our next council meeting there was a
large number of local and non-local
residents applying pressure to the
council and advocating for the tunnel a
before our vote slash our vote
this is I'm sorry I'm reading what he
wrote me a few days before
our vote slash meeting the dot reversed
their decision and said we could be on
the hook financially if we decided that
we wanted the tunnel what a giant waste
of time I would have never put this on
the agenda if we knew we might be on the
hook I asked the dot at least three
times three different ways if we could
be on the hook and was assured no
I worked closely with our town manager
on the crafting of the motion that we
voted on
I wanted it to send the message that the
council was putting this back in the
state's hands and that we were not
supporting spending additional money on
the rail trail
the dot should not use this vote to
justify its position
we were robbed of our vote on whether we
supported the tunnel or not that is the
most frustrating part of all of this
I implore you to do your due diligence
and call each counselor and ask them
what they thought they were voting on
I'm willing to bet that they voted not
to spend a dime more and that each and
every one of them
would say
do not tie this to whether or not we
support the tunnel
I'm not saying how that vote would have
gone but only that you know that the
vote meant what the vote meant to us and
that due to the Dot's flip-flop we did
not vote in support or against the
tunnel
and I'll read that line again I'm not
saying how that vote would have gone but
only that only that you know what the
and that due to the Dot's flip-flop we
did not vote in support or against the
tunnel please call me if you would like
any information of any member of the
Derry Town Council I would be happy to
provide it sign Josh Borden with his
phone number included
[Music]
now for my disclosure so I sit on
legislative Administration and we have
the Monumental task of dealing with the
ethics rules of the house
so in the spirit of that even though I'm
not required to I will disclose that I
am a member of the dairy uh
rail trail board the board owns Mill
real property it has no taxing Authority
it makes no rules and only exists at the
grace of the town to probably primarily
pick up garbage and pull weeds that is
that board
so
in reference to Chairman Borden's letter
one of the things
um he references is a meeting a meeting
that I was at
and I want to reiterate the fact that
his words are true three separate
occasions bluntly asked
if the dairy was on the hook for
anything and the answer was always no
so imagine my surprise in the surprise
of the chairman and vice chairman of the
council when they received that
threatening letter from the chairman or
excuse me the the commissioner of the
Department of Transportation
indicating what you which I believe you
and if you don't it's a letter of
November 28th it's a letter dated note
December 14th I believe okay probably
it's in the package
we're also going to provide you a copy
that contract that was you requested at
this is on file with Secretary of
State's office
so as discussed in this this contract
um it it to surmise we we mentioned it
in the other work session that basically
it says each of the towns are required
foreign
but we have the benefit of the law
offices of Wilmer Hale his
interpretation of the contract at our at
the request of
um
the rail trail Organization for them to
look over this contract to make sure
that when
the contract was discussed and addressed
that they were speaking properly and and
correctly
so I'll start with the the first thing
in the second bullet point down given
the reconsideration at this point in the
design there is a school of thought that
the town should bear responsibility for
additional costs
it's not a coincident that that was sent
right before the Town Council is going
I don't know if it's proper for the
estate agency to attempt to manipulate a
local Town Council that way
but please don't be lost in the timing
of that
because it seems clear to me that that
was that intention of sending that email
the law offices of Wilmer Hale in Boston
are a massive outfit they have offices
all over the globe
in the U.S and in Europe
and they looked it over and they came up
and not going to read it to you but they
came up with two points first that
there's no legal basis on which the
Department of Transportation could
require the town of Derry to contribute
additional funds to the project even if
the Town Council votes to support the
planned tunnel under Folsom Road in the
Manchester and Lawrence railroad
historic district the town's 2015
agreement with the D.O.T unambiguously
limits the town's financial
responsibility of the project to 5
million
the second point they brought up
was removing the tunnel from the project
would delay not expedite this project as
we've discussed before that tunnel was
part of the planned submission that was
federally approved
years ago
a supplemental environmental impact
statement would be required for new
federal approval for the project if the
tunnel is removed and preparing the
supplemental Eis would take at least
several months
and they go on to get into specifics but
that is the gist of the the opinion of
the law offices of Wilmer Hale which has
when the town entered into this contract
we we had to float a bond is five
million dollars the town of dairy is not
of size where we can simply just take
five million dollars and and spend it
like that
so the the people of my community
consented to to pay the 5 million they
voted for the bond we we floated it and
paid it
so for the Department of Transportation
to send
an email stating
that now the town could be on the hook
for other elements
the people of the town of Derry did not
vote to do that they did not consent to
that
they consented to paying the five
million dollars and appearing to the
contract
if it's not going to be the position of
the Department of Transportation that
the town of Derry
has paid what they are required and
they're going to be asked for more
outside the parameters of this contract
then I think we have a substantially
bigger problem in the fact that my
and without that consent because of the
involvement of so much local Road
this project should stop immediately
the elements specific to other aspects
of this I'll let the folks that are
experts behind me touch on
I'm not an expert in rail trails
but
my job as a state representative is to
protect my constituents
and convey messages from my local
officials and that is what I've done for
you here now so
if there's any additional questions to
this I'm more than happy to take them
and
we can go on to some other elements
questions for representative Pearson
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
being here the 2015 contract without
reading it through fully
um did it outline which route was going
to be utilized for the rail trail
no the contract doesn't indicate the
route for the rail trail it also doesn't
indicate the route for the road either
it indicates the project thank you Mr
thank you representative so it
references the project anywhere in here
does it say that the town of dairies
Town Council can vote to alter the plan
change the plan approve the project
before or does it still relegate all
that responsibility to the State
Department of Transportation there are
elements in here that involve the
cooperation between the towns and the
state
um as far as the specifics to the back
and forth of that the Department of
Transportation has had many many
meetings with local officials for years
in reference to this
so
um
how that's outlined in here I'd have to
read through and really dissect that as
far as the specifics but from the
practical application there has been a
relationship back and forth going back
into the 80s really into when the
precipice of this concept became a thing
so I I would just call that if if it's
not spelled out here it's long
established practice
one more question thank you chairman
thank you again sure so again I I'm
aware this has been going on for years
at what stage in the process whether
that be a date or a general time period
did the route that the dot was pursuing
become
contentious for the residents
this is a federal approval yes okay so
the the plan that was brought before us
Mr Keith Cota who was the project
manager at the time a fellow that I
spent a lot of time on the phone with
um
they submitted this to Federal Highway
this is approved by the fed's dated
February 3rd of 2020 the Federal Highway
approval will have the original design
had the Box tunnel in it that's that's
what was federally approved
and this is uh you'll receive a copy of
the approval from the feds
so at some point after the bid build
process was abandoned
a one of the engineering firms submitted
a design that was outside the scope of
that of what was asked
and the Department of Transportation
took that when the when that process
ended they received all of the paperwork
and the documents and all the stuff from
those bidding contractors
and at some point they decided to start
down that road
we didn't know about it until we had two
public hearings at the middle school
um both of which had maps on the wall
that contained the tunnel
and the first public hearing
for the citizens of dairy to outline
this was in September of last year
which is way late in the process
substantially into the time period where
they knew that they were going they were
looking at a change
and
really as we were told too late
so a public hearing that's supposed to
be getting input from the citizens of my
town really was more of a dictation than
it was a was an input session
they should have called for a public
Hearing Way sooner when they knew there
was a change that was going to be made
and we this was a blind side to local
and then that started the ball rolling
with the various the various affected
groups and and townsfolks that were
saying what is this so
um representative O'Brien was probably
the first one really to to recognize
this and and kind of say hey what's
going on here so
this is this is well after the fed's
approved
seeing now and I do we have one
were you ever given a reason why the
department didn't hold it public hearing
after changes were made to the tunnel
plan or
I don't recall ever asking them that so
I
I don't know I know that we had we had
attempted to do it in August and there
was an air conditioning issue with the
middle school but that's a month so it's
not really one month is really not in
question here
um but no I don't I don't know I don't
have an answer why they didn't
stay around
thanks for your I will thank you sir
I do see another sponsor here
representative O'Brien
thank you so much uh and I go by prude
home O'Brien so I'm not confused with
representative Michael O'Brien of Nashua
I wouldn't want that to happen I hope it
wouldn't
that would really
really okay for me
um
anyway uh
I want to answer some of the questions
that just came up the first time I saw
the convoluted spaghettified more
complicated passageway I remember the
day it was October 28 2021 and the plans
were unveiled to the community at a
meeting at the municipal center it was
packed I could barely get around the
room and I remember this because I went
directly to the plans to look at the
rail trail Crossing and I had a very
strong reaction when I saw that and I
started asking the man who was standing
next to the plans who's an engineer
questions about it and he couldn't
answer my questions and sent me over to
some other Engineers on the project who
told me that the reason why they wanted
to do it was to save money because they
would save about seven hundred and
seventy thousand dollars because since
they already have to pass over Shield
Brook why not just have a passing there
we had no idea and I'm saying and we the
community had no idea that this was an
option and I've mentioned last time this
would have been outside of the realm of
my imagination and I went and spoke to
those other engineers and then I sat
down next to Tom card in a former Town
counselor who is here and basically had
a conversation that was akin to what
intonation because
I could like I said I couldn't have
imagined it and it seems very complex
and since then I have been making many
many phone calls about this uh to
Department of Transportation of
officials
um safety and officials with the
Department of Transportation the last
conversation I had with the Department
of Transportation official
because the gist of every single one of
my conversations was what do we do next
how do we communicate to the Department
of Transportation that this is not the
best choice and that's what my
constituents have consistently been
telling me they're not happy with this
passageway that is the spaghettified
complex that has many navals labels
and what I was told last was the Town
Council needs to weigh in we need to
hear from the Town Council well
reading this letter it seems to me like
the you know the thumb was on the scale
and and listening to the Town Council
appreciate your testimony and spending
the time with me and representative
wheeler out there last Thursday yeah
thank you for coming
um
you said something that
caught my attention
they've proposed a 63-foot bridge
according to the letter I have that was
sent out on November 28th by the
Commissioner's Office do you know and
that's where the scenic spaghetti Trail
goes do you know if they had a 63-foot
bridge initially in the plan because to
me that seems like
a rather expensive fix for that existing
60 inch culvert
I'm not really sure I have observed
Bridges being reconstructed in my
community such as on fordway extension
and I know that the thinking now is to
go much wider to accommodate for any
potential flooding in that is an area
where there has been flooding so that is
a concern
um
there's just a lot of concerns with that
um and I I'm I've expressed
um everything I've I can think of right
at this moment but I wanted to I wanted
to make make clear to you that when I
first began to ask about this that day
October 28 2021
um
that I was told it was to save money and
I was pretty surprised by the I was
pretty shocked really this whole thing
again thanks for your testimony are
there any questions for the gentlelady
from dairy that's easier than
remembering your hyphenated name
thank you thanks I'd like to call on
someone from the Department of
Transportation since uh
you're very much part of this debate
and if you could identify yourselves for
the record and if you have a difficult
last name spell it for a clerk please
thank you Mr chair and good afternoon
good afternoon members of the committee
for the record my name is David
Rodriguez rod
r-i-g-u-e and I am the assistant
commissioner for the Department of
Transportation with me today is Wendy
thank you my name is Wendy Johnson I'm
the nhdot project manager for the dairy
Londonderry project
[Music]
so good afternoon I I would like to go
through
um the Department's position on this
issue I do want to preface by saying
there have been some significant
allegations made throughout different
testimonies from other people my intent
is not to get into a back and forth on
allegations and and other things I
appreciate the fact that your other
hearings you talked about the
misdemeanor portions of the law of the
bill and I have confidence that those
will be removed but I'd like to go ahead
with my testimony
the Department of Transportation
supports the scenic route adjacent to
Shields Brook and does not support the
tunnel the primary reasons that the
department does not support the tunnel
is a delay in connecting exit 4A with
Folsom Road the increase in design and
construction cost in the increased
long-term maintenance costs for the town
of Derry
a number of points I'd like to be clear
on the department has worked with the
towns of dairy in Londonderry throughout
the design of the overall exit for a
project
the town of dairy continues to support
the Department's proposed Scenic Trail
alignment adjacent to Shields Brook and
I think you have a memo from Dave Karen
the town manager or the Town
Administrator for the town of dairy
the scenic not not to interrupt but you
probably just heard that we have a
letter from the president of the council
conf the conflicting information that's
what we're wrestling with because I
agree with you that we'd like to move on
get a resolution of this none of us are
going getting anywhere quickly by
pointing fingers one way the other but
we need to get a resolution because
again we're hearing conflicting reports
emails letters from the town just today
that we hadn't heard before from the
council president so
um and can continue but I think we just
we need to get to a solution here
because I think both sides are probably
in
um agreement that they're not happy with
the situation so hopefully we can get to
a a good point a
and and I'm confident that that we can
I'm confident that that we can
so the again the we've worked with the
towns of dairy and Londonderry the
Scenic Trail alignment adjacent to
Shields Brook wilmie ADA requirements
the Scenic Trail alignment will be safe
independent of the tunnel or Scenic
Trail alignment a crosswalk will be
installed on Folsom Road at the
intersection with North High Street to
connect pedestrians using the sidewalks
on those roads
changing to a tunnel will cost more
money to design construct and maintain
and redesign for the Box Culvert will
delay the opening of Old Rum Trail and
Folsom Road from I-93 to New Hampshire
route 102. those are the basic premises
for the Department's position and I'll
go through and flesh each one out a
little bit
so the department has worked with the
towns of dairy and Londonderry
throughout the design of the overall
exit for a project the town of Derry
continues to support the Department's
proposed Scenic Trail alignment adjacent
to Shields Brook when I say that I'm
the town of dairy and Londonderry have
worked for over 40 years to progress the
exit for a project to support Economic
Opportunity and to reduce traffic
congestion in downtown Dairy on December
23rd 2015 the department entered into a
state local project agreement with Derry
in Londonderry for the I-93 exit 4A
project the agreement in the addition of
the dairy Londonderry project into the
state's 10-year Transportation
Improvement plan provided local funding
and federal funding in the process for
as well as a process for the design and
construction of the project
the department has and continues to
follow the project agreement in the
process which includes public meetings
and input
the department prepared and advertised a
design build procurement for design and
construction of the project the
procurement was prohibitively expensive
one of the design teams that bid on the
design build procurement had developed a
concept that had both the town of dairy
in the dairy rail trail board support to
provide an open light and scenic route
for the trail under the shields Brook
Bridge with documented cost savings
other benefits and support for the
design the department included this
element in the final design of the
overall 2.3 mile roadway connecting the
new I-93 exit 4A to New Hampshire route
102.
the department is and always has been
committed to providing connectivity of
the rail trail under Folsom road while
the tunnel in the Scenic Trail under
Shields Brook both have advantages and
disadvantages the department is
confident that both designs are safe and
will meet the long-term needs of all
Trail users
since the Scenic Trail route adjacent to
Shield Brooks concept has been selected
the department had a public meeting on
October 28 2021
the department met separately with the
rail trail groups on August 23rd 2022 in
the department had a public
informational meeting on September 22nd
2022.
the public has had input into the
project
the department looks to the town as the
local decision maker and they have been
consistent with us that they do not want
cost increase in that they do not want
delay
change in the current design will lead
to increased cost and additional delays
the trail alignment adjacent to Shields
Brook wilmie ADA requirements the Scenic
Trail design adjacent to Shields Brook
will meet all the requirements of the
American with Disabilities Act
accessibility guidelines
to avoid any section of the rail trail
from being too steep the trail is
lengthened slightly to manage a profile
slope of the path
installation of the other option a
tunnel will actually alter the profile
slope of Folsom Road such as the profile
of the road and the sidewalks along it
will likely exceed that of the rail
trail we expect Folsom Road height will
increase between five and seven feet and
not the profile slope of the road will
increase to somewhere between five and
seven percent
the trail alignment will be safe within
the project limits the trail will cross
ferwin drive a short Dead End Street and
we'll cross two additional driveways
intersecting with Folsom road with
either design the trail will cross
driveways along North High Street within
the project limits these Crossings do
not make the trail unsafe
further south in Dairy the trail runs
concurrently with Courthouse Lane
adjacent to Manning Street and Crosses
West Broadway at grade so at street
level in run then it runs through a a
parking lot beyond that
independent of the trail alignment a
crosswalk will be installed on Folsom
Road at the intersection of North High
Street can to connect pedestrians on the
sidewalk
the project will install sidewalks along
Old Rum Trail Folsom Road into Cento
Road as well as intersecting roads at
North High Street and Manchester Road
the signalized intersections along the
corridor will have pedestrian Crossings
providing pedestrian safe passage
regardless of the trail alignment
similar six-lane crosswalks currently
exist at many locations around New
Hampshire
including in Dairy currently at Folsom
Road in Manchester Road
changing to a tunnel will cost more
money to design construct and maintain
final design of the project has
progressed with the trail adjacent to
Shields Brook a change in design at this
point will require the department to
negotiate an increase scope and fee with
our design consultant increasing the
cost of the design the tunnel is
estimated to add more than 770
000 to the cost of construction this
estimate includes subtracting the
savings from not building the Scenic
Trail under the bridge
there will also be additional costs for
engineering estimated to be about a
hundred and twelve thousand dollars the
cost may rise as the final design
progresses finally if a tunnel is
installed the town of dairy will bear
the future cost of Maintenance the dairy
Town Administrator referring to the
trail adjacent to seal Shields Brook has
publicly stated on a long-term
maintenance basis it's about a third of
the cost to maintain the trail meaning
under Shields Brook
redesigned for the box cover will delay
the opening of Old Rum Trail in Folsom
Road from I-93 to New Hampshire route
102. the department is aware that this
committee has received a letter from the
town of Derry with background
information and action taken by the
dairy Town Council we believe the letter
is a fair description of the process the
town has made it very clear to us they
do not want any delay and they do not
want cost increases the department
currently has a town of dairy support
for the trail adjacent to Shields Brook
and does not intend to change a design
causing additional delay and increased
cost should a law be passed to require a
tunnel the department will be forced to
to take the following steps we'll
discuss with the town of dairy the
requirement any law may be imposing on
the roadway that the town will own
operate maintain to determine how best
to comply with any law passed we'll
negotiate a scope and fee with our
design consultant to incorporate the
design change we'll seek Federal Highway
approval of that scope and fee we'll
seek their approval for an updated
estimate approving the change in cost
will request governor and Council
approval for the scope and fee with our
design consultant we'll issue a notice
to proceed complete new geotechnical
work for the tunnel option design review
and approve changes in line and grade
will design review and approve slope and
drain we'll have new utilities
submissions in review
will draft environmental permits and
Wetland plans for review and approval by
the department we'll submit those plans
for approval by regulating agencies will
draft right-of-way plans
we'll go through the right-of-way plan
process of appraisal and acquisitions
will develop preliminary plan
specifications and estimates submission
and review and final plan specifications
and estimates prior to advertising the
project
the above process is estimated to delay
the static construction for the project
from 2024 to 2025 and ultimately delay
the connection of exit 4A to Folsom Road
the work of the Department of
Transportation impacts every citizen
every day when it comes to planning
designing and constructing our state
transportation system we have a robust
tenure plan process that includes public
hearings legislative approvals and
signature by the governor when it comes
to individual project designs we work
closely with communities and we host
public
meetings to receive public input in the
case of the dairy Londonderry exit 4A
project we are designing and
constructing a roadway system that will
be owned maintained and operated by the
towns of dairy and Londonderry we have
hosted public meetings with the towns
and ensured the interests of the public
have been heard while we have not
satisfied everyone the current design is
supported by the town of dairy the
ultimate owner of the project we are
providing safe open Scenic Trail
connectivity and we have considered
project cost long-term maintenance costs
and schedule
thank you very much for hearing my
testimony and I'll take any questions
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you Ms
Johnson and Mr Rodriguez
um in front of you on the table are two
maps
um the one in yellow I got from your
website it was dated October 2022 is
yes
for the question yes the answer is yes
and the other one is from Google Earth
it shows the current state of this area
is that accurate also yes yes okay good
so
on the on the design plan
I see a traffic light at the corner of
Folsom Road and North High Street
correct correct okay and I see a
crosswalk going across the street
presumably with some Walk Don't Walk
control yes correct okay
so why is it that that in itself is not
adequate for this Trail
be because we support a grade separated
Crossing this is a busy road
um the the rail trail is a very well
used facility and we support a grade
grade separated Crossing for that Rail
Trail
so we want to separate that heavy
traffic on the rail trail from having to
interact with with
um the vehicles on the newly constructed
roadway it's very true if you go north
into Londonderry the rail trail crosses
Route 28 a very busy road it's two lanes
at that location
um and it's an at-grade Crossing so
people have to wait for a gap in in the
traffic but this is a new facility and
it was a great time to provide that
grade separation for the rail trail
users
so what you're saying is
at this other location where it
intersects Route 28
there is a traffic light and a crosswalk
no no I'm sorry there's no traffic light
at that location the the trail uses
simply need to stop wait for a gap in
traffic and choose choose the time they
cross all right but here they would they
would have a walk light that lets them
go yes so be less dangerous yeah that
that is one potential alternative so one
of one of the the things I tried to get
at in my testimony when when the
department proposes a design like this
there are many Alternatives there are
there are many options and we work with
the communities to find the best option
at a cost we can afford in a schedule
that we can afford the department from
the beginning of this project has
supported a grade separated Crossing we
believe that the currently post on on
this plan that that you pointed out to
the currently proposed Crossing
underneath the shields Brook bridge is
the best balance of of those things of
safety and of Costa Effectiveness and us
but do you really think that someone
given the choice of waiting at a
crosswalk versus adding this long
um
trust this long passage via turning
right going under going over
Etc why would anyone use that right or
wouldn't someone I mean if I were there
I and I was there I mean I I walked this
area
um I would think I would just wait for
the light and cross no
that's an option that users will have I
can tell you this will be a beautiful
Trail so people use the trail for all
different reasons they use a trail to
get some perhaps directly from point A
to point B others to recreate to enjoy
time with their their families their
their dogs or whatever on the trail a
walk under that under that bridge by the
Brook is going to be a nice part of that
experience for people and that's a was a
major early on incentive to locate the
trail yes it was a cost savings but
there's also a firm belief by many of us
that this Trail is it's not a circuitous
spaghetti path that ruins people's
experience it will interrupt somebody
and make it a little longer if you're
trying to get from A to B this is going
to be a nice Trail this is going to be
derry's Trail you have committed people
who have testified that keep this Trail
up nice and this will be a nice place
for them to do that that's the
Department's belief What would would be
the cost savings if you only had the
crosswalk and did not include this the
when Wendy will answer that
so um there was a couple questions asked
earlier that I I want to sort of address
somebody had asked the current bridge is
63 feet and would the if we got rid of
the the trail underneath would the
bridge size be shorter and the answer to
that is no the bridge was always 63 feet
so in this particular case if you got
rid of the trail that goes underneath
the only thing you would be saving is if
you notice that purple line which comes
around the purple line is needed for
pedestrian connectivity up North High
Street it's also needed for pedestrian
connectivity going along Folsom road so
the only savings you would have would be
the purple that comes around and
underneath and reconnects back on this
side so that would be the only cost
savings that you would you would have
I see because there's sidewalks on both
sides of Folsom Road that's correct so
we're basically reusing that same
facility
um if it were to be if it were to be
changed and you can take a look at the
the top of the page you can see that
there's a narrower purple strip so the
one on the top of the sheet is only six
feet wide whereas the one on the bottom
is wider because it's going to be more
multi-use so you could have
um more people traveling on it
further questions uh representative
Sweeney thank you Mr chair thank you
both for for testifying today
the so the Box tunnel that the members
of the town want was that the plan
approved by the federal government when
so when we so that's an interesting
question so when we present something to
the federal government a concept goes
over and so the concept is what what
where we've been talking about this
preliminary plan that's what everybody's
been talking about and so the the plan
isn't necessarily something that is this
is what's in the plan this is exactly
what needs to be maintained this is what
has to happen because things change as
you go through design so what they
approve is is a general concept overall
so overall what we had agreed to at the
time of the Federal Highway approval was
as as Dave had pointed out a grade
separated
um a grade separated uh weight across
the roadway but we never said it's
definitely has to be here or
definitively has to be there and there
has been a lot of talk about a secondary
Federal approval and what that is is
something called a NEPA reevaluation and
that's something that we're working
towards with this with this alternative
and what that means is originally when
we had when we had that graphic we might
not have had the footprint come all the
way up here where that purple is we
might not have had that come all the way
up here
so the NEPA reevaluation asks us to go
back and they say are you guys impacting
any more archaeological resources are
there any other issues that you're going
to be impacting aside from what you
would have impacted with that big
environmental impact statement
originally and in this particular case
we do have a couple extra little areas
that we've taken a look at we don't have
any additional archaeological impacts so
the reevaluation is something we're
currently working on we don't yet have a
date for a completion on that simply
because we're waiting for what sort of
comes out of here before we keep pushing
in One Direction
one one more question thank you I'm
channeling my uh representative McGuire
today
when this contract was sent to the towns
of dairy and Londonderry in December of
2015 was there an implied concept for
I don't want to say sold to but was
there an understanding of a project that
included a box tunnel or was it a
project that would go from point A to B
however safest what was what was the
Contra what under what assumptions
was the contract pursued and signed by
the parties so in 2015 it would have
been some sort of grade separated I
wasn't on the project at that time but
it's likely that it probably did have
the visual look of the tunnel that's at
that location but I couldn't necessarily
couldn't confirm that right now I could
I could take a look at the paper but
that's likely what was shown publicly at
that time appreciate it thank you very
much
thank you and thank you to the
department for being here um I've worked
with you over at public works for 10
years and I've always had the highest
respect for your work and your process
and I appreciate everything that you've
done on this project
um
so there's also been statements that
this Trail would be subject to flooding
when folks are talking about how uh
didn't make any sense for it to be there
could you talk a little bit about the
perfect
um so there's been a lot of questions
about the the bridge and we're going to
go back to that 63 foot again the bridge
is 63 feet because what we have
underneath there is we have a flood
plain that goes underneath there and
when we have a water crossing we have to
meet something called Full bank with so
that means that we take a look at where
the bank is and we keep making it wider
and wider and wider so we can Encompass
the whole Bridge so in in the whole
water body so in this particular case
the bridge needed to be 63 feet and so
we were able to still add the the tunnel
I mean the trail it goes right
underneath we're still able to add that
and as long as we don't make it go
higher than the 100 Year floodplain when
then we can go ahead and we can add the
trail underneath so if you're in those
smaller storm events like a two-year
storm or something like that so A two
percent chance of a storm occurring in a
particular year you're not going to have
any problems with the trail itself as
far as flooding is concerned you get all
the way up above the 50-year storm you
know there's but you have one in a
chance 50 years of this storm coming
along that's when you could potentially
have flooding but it's it's just like
you see right now with other other
locations the water comes up and the
water comes down so that's how we're
designing it so the water can be within
those materials and not affect the trail
so if it if the water comes up we're not
going to have to rebuild we're not going
to have to rebuild that path every time
that it rains and then um as as you had
indicated there's also the at grade
crossing so if it does flood there is
still the ad grade crossing that could
happen of course with a tunnel if you
went underneath the roadway you would
still have those same concerns because
the tunnel that's over here no matter
which option you have they both have to
go down they both have to go underneath
the roadway so that means that it comes
down and it goes under and that's a
perfect place for water to pond so
whether you're looking at the tunnel
option or you're looking at the combined
structure option you're still going to
have the same situation and a flood
event
foreign
so could you describe the difference
between the plan that was discussed with
dairy and
had the support of the rail trail folks
in 2020
versus the current Shield Brook proposal
do you understand my question because
they had subsequently pulled their
recommendation yep absolutely so um and
I'll kind of go do a little bit of
History to go with it so yes the
original design that went out to the
design build groups had the tunnel in it
and so when the teams went out they're
all looking for ways to make the project
better faster cheaper that's what
they're looking for because that's how
they're going to gain the contract
they're looking for innovation
so they took a look at the options and
they came up with this this secondary
the secondary alternative which is um
something that we've been called an
alternative technical concept so the
alternative technical concept looks very
similar to what's shown in in purple
right along the bottom of the sheet the
difference between the one that was
shown in 2020 and the one that's shown
now is the one that was in 2020 was
lower and hugged more closely the
property that's on this bottom part of
the page
and then what we've done is we have
um the the connection across the bottom
of Folsom Road still the same coming
around furland Drive is still about the
same except in this option we've widened
the trail to 15 feet around the corner
here when it was 10 feet during the
alternative technical concept and we've
softened some of the curves along here
so it's basically the same plan with a
few tweaks to make it a nicer experience
and perhaps improve the safety so I just
had maybe a couple more questions
um
so
I realize there's a legal opinion
sitting here but as I understood the
contract that you had with dairy in
Londonderry
they paid their 10 million dollars and
they basically you were going to
continue to have stakeholder meetings
and get input but they basically were
turning the design and administration of
exit 4A over to you so the 10 million
dollars was really for the exit design
including the rail trail and everything
and if I further read the document it
looked to me like once they turned it
over to you once you did all your
stakeholder meetings and a design
process had been set
if Dairy then came back and wanted to
change something once this train was out
of the station you could come back to
them and say if you really want to make
this change then you're on the hook for
is that the I think that's that's one
way to read the agreement the agreement
certainly allows the ability of the
department and the town to negotiate
increased cost once it exceeds the
estimated costs the original estimated
cost and that cost was exceeded a long
time ago yes
which I would think was what
commissioner Cass was alluding to in the
in the letter that he sent I don't I
don't
I think he was clearly clearly stating
that
um so that so that the town knows the
expectation yes okay and then I just
it's really important or would you agree
it's really important that this project
not for the rail trail not be viewed
as an isolated thing but to be viewed as
part of the exit 4A project in totality
and when you think about it you think
about the if that you think about the
trail but you're also thinking about
what a long process it's been and the
potential delay does affect the entire
for a project and not just the
development of the rail trail is that
correct oh ABS absolutely I refer to the
this rail trail Crossing as an element
of the design and when you put it in the
scope of the entire project from
exit 4A on on 93 all the way to its
Terminus 2.3 miles later at Route 102
this is a very small element however it
is an important element and I can't
stress that enough it pains me to to be
sitting here and to hear some of the
allegations because we are not proposing
a terrible situation we are not
proposing the the awfullest of of grades
this has the potential to be a a very
enjoyable experience for the trail the
trail users and that's what we want and
we're not done investing in the in the
trail the town has applied for and
received a transportation Alternatives
project to extend the trail further to
to the north this is what we do with
this is part of the Department of
Transportation
representative evil
Could you
um summarize to the best of your ability
the effect of potentially a year delay
on the completion of the foray project
when you think of all the people that
are relying on its prompt completion
um
so so that is very difficult for for for
me to do other than to to say as has
been stated many times this project has
languished since the 80s there there has
been a very difficult time getting
everybody on the same page getting the
funding in line and getting a process to
get this project done in 2015 that
responsibility was handed handed to the
department and we do have a
responsibility to meet our deadlines to
the best that we can we certainly have a
responsibility to meet our budget to to
the best that we can and that is really
what we're trying to do in this case
there's no no doubt costs have increased
and costs will continue to to increase
increase but we design our projects with
a consideration to fiscal
to to be fiscally responsible and
further questions by a division member
sure
thank you Mr chairman have you acquired
these two large buildings and when is
the current plan to demolish them and
break ground in this area so to to
clarify you're talking about the one to
this side another one to this side we do
own both of those structures
there's still one tenant that is in one
of the properties and is waiting until
winter to vacate the story The Brewery
correct
um there are two these both we own both
these buildings these are both under our
13065 e project which is slated to
advertising June of this year so they'll
be demolished After we receive approval
for the project
and after that you would break ground
and start building this yellow road yeah
so the yellow Road would be part of our
B project which is the project that has
the the tunnel on it so
these two will go way ahead of the way
so as a follow-up to representative
McGuire's question how many properties
have you yet to acquire
between 93 and
102 or 28 or no it's a 2.3 mile project
right so how many three point it's 2.3
miles 2.3 yeah it's 2.3 miles and the
project is broken up into different
different projects different sub
projects so we've already advertised and
constructed that first project which is
right at the interstate proper we've
acquired all of those properties already
the B project has 65 properties on it
and 10 full Acquisitions and so you
still have like 50 that you have not
acquired at least no what well what's
what's the B project what is it yeah
where is B project is that the area
that's colored here that
because that's the first time I've heard
a project B project
so into Mr representative McGuire's
question I guess we're looking at more
we were attempting to avoid going to the
plans but we will go to the plans
so um yeah there we go so what I what
I've got shown here is I've got
um the the project so you can see that
there's the brown project on the far
side that's the a project That's The
Interchange proper that's the one we're
building right now
the green one in the middle that's this
one right here that's the one that's got
the trail on it and then this one right
here this is the C project which is
tornado Road and we've got work on the
28 Bypass uh and 28 over here so the the
dots themselves are the first round of
building demolitions that we already did
and the there's the three properties
that you've noticed two of them and the
third one is the Salvation Army property
those three will be advertised in June
for demolition so that's this project
right right here and there are still 50
properties to obtain in the that green
area yeah so it's about 50 here and
there's about a hundred more in this
location
so you had talked about what happens if
we delay any of the work here delaying
the work
um you know the the people that live
along this Corridor are very
they're they're stressed and they they
want to get this project going they want
to see the improvements in front of
their house so extending the project any
duration is also going to bring added
stress to the to the the people of dairy
I'm just speaking for myself here but if
you still have at least 50 properties to
obtain how can you start the project
unless you've got all those properties
under agreement
so that's a good question so what we're
doing is we're prioritizing the projects
because the B project advertises next
and then the C advertises after that so
we're working currently on the
Acquisitions for the B project which are
the the like you said the 55-ish we have
left and then we're going to move on to
the to the C project and at some point
the B and the C will be acquiring them
at the same time we're using a
consulting firm to do all of our
appraisals and all of our Acquisitions
and they believe that they can acquire
the properties on time
so again just speaking for myself
you folks have said
um better faster cheaper I think that
was what you said
but if you can't acquire those
properties uh
how is this tunnel going to really
impact I mean you could take years I sat
on a commission to acquire properties in
Nashville years ago there's
circumferential Highway and one of the
biggest obstacles to that being built
costs but acquiring property so yeah I'm
a little concerned about
what's going to really cause the delay
here the tunnel
the acquisition of the properties so we
have the time in the schedule for the
acquisition of the properties
um I'm not sure what your situation was
on the circumferential highway but here
we have the right to condemn so it's not
one of those things where it can be an
ongoing we get to a certain point we
follow the process and the guidelines we
make offers and we go through all of
that and then we can acquire the
property
um so that won't that won't slow us down
but it's also not going to stop us from
doing amicable negotiations either you
know we want to make sure we get out
there and we're fair to everyone on the
property on the project so I appreciate
you taking my questions I have a few
more
so
obviously there are a lot of people
upset
however direction we take with this it
would seem the simplest answer at least
again speaking for myself that someone
whether it be the state or you know if
we were King for the day I would just
write a check for 750 000 because if
someone
that
uses rail Trails as far as hiking and
biking it would seem that much more
practical if you had the tunnel now I
also observed went to the site last
Thursday and I observed a large six foot
Culvert that's under maiden or Madden
Road I guess it's called
so there was already a passage under
there before and traditionally railroad
bridges are well in excess of I think 16
and a half 17 feet and there was a
bridge there so it seemed to make sense
to to me again not an expert but to put
that tunnel in I think a lot of people
would be very happy the biking Community
I looked at the usage allowed on that
trail it's like snowmobile use and I'm
looking at the scenic
so-called Scenic Trail down to Shields
Brook and I can't imagine a snowmobile
like maneuvering around those curves so
I'm just very concerned again I would
hope that we can get to a solution
because they think the representatives
from dairy have made some strong points
I think you've made some strong points
as far as minimizing the cost but I
think there's a win in here for somebody
for maybe everybody but if the
department you know digs himself and we
can't do this or the proponents of the
tunnel are not really willing to
compromise and it would appear that
we're not going to get somewhere but
I'd like to see what you both would have
to offer David or
because obviously the department wants
something safe I think all of us do
but
I can't see where this
crosswalk that goes over six plus Lanes
of traffic is ideal for somebody that's
riding a bike they have to wait or they
say I'm going to run across here and
um
so again I've said enough I'd like to
hear a little more from you as how we
make this thing work so we can walk away
where people are fairly happy with what
we've decided
sure thank you thank you for your
question
um I'm going to invite Wendy to pull up
another one of her plans with the
profile that that will
um show answer some of your questions
but I want to add a a few points as as
well
um so it is in fact true that at one
point I believe it was Madden Road did
go over the the railroad this new
alignment is no Madden Road and this new
alignment is not going in the same
location as Madden Road hence you you
see the building demolition so the new
road will be considerably lower than
Madden Road as you were out there
looking and as you saw that pipe
underneath my Madden Road I'm sure you
noticed the water in it and I'm sure you
noticed the Bramble down below I don't
think a lot of people are cutting
through that today nor do I think that
that was the the full intent of that but
I don't know and then following on to
the snowmobile use there are rural
trails that that absolutely that's a
great use the the trails I saw in Derry
the rail trail portions they're mostly
plowed they're they're most what I
observed is mostly pedestrian activity I
don't know if I would expect snowmobiles
along that portion of the corridor not
saying it couldn't couldn't happen
that's that's there is will be dairy's
rail trail
um but I think it's much heavier
pedestrian activity Wendy
so good so I think
um so this is sort of a comparison of
everything that we've been talking about
um so this is so the green dash line
here is your existing ground condition
the the blue line is what we're
currently proposing in this red line up
here would have been what would have
been underneath that 2015 sort of time
frame that's that preliminary plan
so as you look at this let's start with
the preliminary plan when you look at
the preliminary plan one of the other
reasons that we were talking about
wanting to change it is is you're come
down on the red line
and you're looking at about a 2.7 grade
right here that's that proposed box
Culvert that we've been talking about
you come down about 7.1 percent grade
you hit the shields Brook bridge and
then Franklin Street so it was also a
concern with the original design that
you're becoming in at a 7.1 grade right
into the signalized intersection so that
was one other thing that we were trying
to address by combining the Box Culvert
with with the bridge
so in the revised option when you don't
have the tunnel to go up and over
anymore
you come down at about a 2.9 percent
grade and then it comes down to 3.64 and
then it stays around 2.3 so the one
thing to note here is you have
pedestrians on this road too this is
where your pedestrians that purple box I
was showing you so your pedestrians are
going to have to walk 7.1 percent and
there's going to be a hump in the road
so that's why we wanted to to do this
and I know that there's a lot of people
who are going to say well why don't we
just lower the box and do that and then
we don't have to worry about it and we
have what we have here is we have some
high bedrock at this location and we
also have a groundwater issue so the
lower we make this the wetter and the
darker and this is always going to be
full of water and we don't we don't want
that so
does that answer your question somewhat
yeah okay
is is there a clarifying point I could
help with
well I looked at the topography out
there and it's very steep like you said
and then as you get closer hitting North
told towards Londonderry it actually
remains pretty significant and then it
drops off very sharply where the trail
would come in it was a very steep
banking down to Shields Brook I believe
um
I guess I'll take a break for questions
other members of the division
yes representative Griffin
I have a question thank you Mr chairman
I have a question I'm not sure whether
it's to you at the Wendy but
you talked about the properties that
still need to be
purchased to complete the project and we
talked earlier about the extended time
that would result from going to
the tunnel aspect
were you trying to
make a link there where those those two
things made overlap
or are they consecutive
you're very perceptive for
representative Griffin
because again it would seem to me unless
you get all those properties you're not
going to go out and put the project out
to bid especially if there's some that
significantly impact the proposed Road
yeah and that's where I get back to that
timeline We Believe with the current
timeline that we have with the current
impacts with their that we're showing we
can make the advertising date if we
change where the where the tunnel is and
we change where the location is it
changes the impacts of those properties
so essentially it starts those
Acquisitions over if if you go in in
that direction so if we keep moving
there is no delay but if you have to
redo all the properties because you'd
basically have to come back from all the
properties west of Franklin Street
reassess all the impacts and reacquire
any land in that area although we
haven't acquired the land we're working
on appraisals and we're doing that sort
of thing so we're we're far along in in
the process
could we pin you down and when you say
far along is that you anticipate
acquiring all these properties within
two weeks or two years they will be
acquired within like the
11 months
but because there are there are a lot of
properties there and we don't do them
all at once that was my concern they're
actually a lot of properties there there
are but we have a big team
um and we're we're taking care of it
it's in our schedule
so one of the issues that came up I
asked about the zoning in that area and
they said most of the area has now been
rezoned I believe there was a member of
the planning board there
so the properties where this proposed
the Getty Scenic Trail runs will
probably become commercial properties
and there are several homes there how is
that going to impact this Scenic Trail
if you've got you know a 7-Eleven there
or something because this is going to
become a major
intersection
I would guess looking at it
so I did ask that the town if there was
any zoning changes and I didn't get any
any idea that there were going to be any
zoning changes coming so zoning changes
are not part of the Department's project
foreign
if I may just following up again the
zoning would be the responsibility of
the town and I honestly look at it both
ways
um you know what what we don't know if
if indeed it is commercial development
the rail trail could provide a great
opportunity for customers to to get to
that commercial development maybe it's a
7-Eleven or maybe it's something that
that the trail uses would appreciate
um again it pains me to see this
characterized as some awful Draconian
solution we honestly feel and and this
solution came about as a way of
improving the experience for the people
on the on the rail trail not ruining the
rail trail for for folks in in Dairy and
we honestly believe it will improve the
representative hatch for sure
thank you just just to concern back to
uh I don't want to beat a horse to death
but in the acquiring the properties I
think of where I live
um near where I live in Jefferson room
two there's been properties that have
been holding that project up for many
many many years
um and I hear 65 to 50 properties
needing to be acquired
um and what you're saying is you're
totally confident
that you'll be able to acquire all these
without any hiccups so to speak that
would uh interfere with this project it
just doesn't comport with me that's yeah
and so yeah no that's a great question
and it is always a sensitive subject but
to be clear we're not buying full
properties either we're maybe buying a
drainage easement from one property or a
slow easement from somebody else so we
have been in contact with our with our
consulting firm they're the ones we've
hired to do this work and they are
confident that we can get the we can get
it done we've seen the schedule and and
we're confident in them
I lost my thought there oh Jefferson
there we go Jefferson was done by
internal staff which is a much smaller
staff than the firm that we've actually
hired which is you know we've got a
handful of Agents six eight agents and
these guys have you know dozens of
Agents they're going to be working on
this so it's it's a little bit different
than an in-house project for
right-of-way acquisition because it's
much more horsepower from the consultant
side
so that that clears it up for me that if
you're not acquiring full properties you
just
um acquiring parts of many yeah so to
speak thank you thank you
representative evil
thank you
um well I guess I would say it's not
like the neighborhood doesn't know this
is coming either right
um
I think
setting aside the financial issue I
think this issue of delay is one that a
lot of people have are concerned about
so the condemnation or the acquisition
uh timeline is going along like this so
if we
require the Box tunnel if if this uh
legislation say passes the house then it
has to go through the Senate then it has
to go so how does it is it really going
to take a year more than the property
acquisition I mean at I'm just trying to
understand the timelines yeah and so
that gets into the schedule that Dave
had talked about is once we change the
impacts to those areas we can't change
those impacts to those areas until we go
through that process that he outlined we
have to do a scope and fee with the
consultant because they've already done
it once so we have to stop telling them
to hold their horses come up with a new
agreement pay them you know figure what
they want to be paid for this this new
version and all those things need to go
through Federal Highway and the governor
and executive Council for approval so
until we get through all those steps we
can't even start to go back to redraw
lines on these plans and so in and it's
not just so much drawing a line on the
plan you've actually got to go and
you've got to put those new those new
profiles on there and figure out where
the water is going and then you you know
that we've got all these different
processes and then you know we have to
figure out what happens to the utility
abilities if we do all this stuff all
that stuff has to be worked out before
we can start doing the right-of-way so
it basically puts a pin in being able to
even start that until we get all the way
back to that point if that makes sense
just follow up so and and you can't
really start any of that until this
legislation passes if it's signed into
right and that could take maybe six
months in another or four months in and
of itself so you have that's an additive
that we're just not really thinking that
much about okay or I wasn't thank you
so the division has several options to
consider at this point we do have an
amendment I think that was offered by
representative Stapleton
to remove uh well it was given to the
committee the committee hasn't accepted
yet that's to remove the
misdemeanor charges against some of our
friends at the dot we
have that before us
we can act on that or we can act on the
bill that we have before us and there's
several options a committee a division
could vote to retain the bill we could
in expedient legislate the bill we could
ought to pass the bill
Mike do you have that amendment that
so the amendment that representative
Stapleton offered
uh again was to remove the
misdemeanor charges that were contained
in the original draft of the spill
but again there are a lot of options for
us to consider
Mr takers
representative evil thank you this isn't
exactly what you had in mind actually
but there's a member of the Town Council
of Derry here and I just wondered if he
would with your forbearance if there
would be anything that he'd like to add
to the conversation I'd be interested to
know for instance whether the email that
we got from Mr born was something that
had been discussed with the council or
or if he'd like to add to the
conversation at all
uh if he wishes to come forward if is
again thank the D.O.T for their
presentation
if you could please state your name for
the record and if your last name again
is difficult to spell
get your PIN thank you Mr chairman
um so my name is Brian churchillo c h
i r i c h i e l l o
I am a member of the Derry Town Council
uh I am in my sixth term
at the Derry Town Council you must enjoy
a punishment oh yeah yeah
um the first thing I want to say is the
letter from chairman Borden was on
himself not uh in correspondence with
the other town councilors so he took it
upon him he's acting on his own opinion
um
as far as the
Acquisitions and whatnot as as it was
mentioned this project has been
discussed since the mid 80s all these
people know it was going down there
they're already they all they already
are prepared for for this to happen so
there'd be no surprises there
as far as the zoning is concerned I'm
also a member of the liaison to the
planning board and spent many years on a
planning board so we started rezoning a
small section
we have not continued to do that further
down
so there's still more rezoning to do but
keep in mind when you rezone there's a
thing that's called grandfathering
so if you are a home and you don't want
to change the commercial if we change
the zoning to Commercial and you want to
keep your home as a home you get to keep
your home as a home
no pressure there
um
there's been so much conversation here
that I really wanted to add in but uh
the five million dollar is Believe It or
Not in the mid 80s the the the
exit 4A and at one time they also
thought about on exit 3A
would have cost 15 million and here we
are today at 104 million
so you can see what happens when you get
when delays happen it just the costs
just keep increasing
um the town of Derry paid
half of that 2.5 million dollars
up front to all the engineering work and
environmental impacts and whatnot we
bonded the the second half of that so
future taxpayers would pay into that
foreign
the discussion that you have to look at
the project as a whole
um and this is to alleviate downtown
traffic in in Derry
because where if you ever take if you
get off the highway exit four and you're
going through the downtown
at gridlocks
and it queues up and what tends to
happen is the people will actually take
these side roads
a lot of these teeny roads that were
never meant for for that that type of
traffic volume so the idea was
that
exit 4A would be an economic driver for
both Londonderry
and Dairy
the extra benefit for dairy would be
would alleviate some traffic and now I
have two paths going east to west
to East
so
and then and then we could actually do
some work on the downtown but anyway I
do want to say that um
I talked to Chairman Borden I do not
believe that the matter should have come
up to the Town Council at the time
because as you were heard in 2015
we basically handed over the keys to the
state and we said we're done Our
obligation is done
here you go they consulted with us
and um when the alternative plan came up
my um
director of Public Works looked at the
plan and said it was acceptable to him
um but he said I would highly recommend
that you go to the drta and and let them
know about it my understanding was is
that they approved
and D.O.T went forward
so it was a cost saver and that's where
we're at and then all of a sudden 18
months later it becomes an issue
and again I'm speaking as myself not as
any other member of the Town Council I'm
just saying the way I I see it
um
and the contract doesn't spell out the
bike path at all or the to me it's the
state's actually doing it for the town
of dairy I think it's a it's a bonus for
us
um and as I said I don't I do not
believe it should have come in front of
the dairy Town Council there was some
discussion as to
uh the the town basically thinking that
it was going to get a tunnel for free if
we pushed it on our on our end and
that's not the case
well also was left out was you saw a
letter from the drt's attorney who's it
from Massachusetts
um but the town actually brought in its
own attorney its Town attorney
and we got we got some counsel from them
saying that yes if we made any changes
we could possibly be on the hook
and everybody on the Town Council had
made a promise to the taxpayers that
five billion dollars would be it we're
not doing any more
so when that time came up to vote in the
Town Council we we voted to pass is
basically what we did we said it's up to
the D.O.T and the state
um
and I think and again as representative
Abel Abel said uh I I actually spent
eight years on transportation and I
think DOD does a fantastic job I watched
the two other subcommittee meetings and
I was a little bit upset because they
they're portrayed as not doing the right
thing and I think that that's incorrect
that's my opinion I'm happy to answer
questions for the gentleman from dairy
representative evil
so
um setting aside again the issue of the
finances it sounds like to the council
the potential for delay was of great
concern
yes thank you representative absolutely
because we've got Economic Development
as well that will offshoot we have
people in the waiting
um some lands off to the side that we
can develop
um and as well my understanding is is
Londonderry has lined up some economic
development as well it's time sensitive
um
the other thing I don't know if was
brought up to you at all but the
landowner
who is going to give the land to the
towns to to maintain on a legendary side
uh for the bike path to connect is a
private landowner
and that private landowner is also
a developer on the Londonderry side
my understanding is is he's not really
happy about AIDS old age
so
um
again we still have to we still have to
see if that landowner will give us the
land because if he doesn't you could
foreign
so you mentioned your concern about the
delays and looking through the
documentation that I've been given by
the department and by the individuals in
Dairy that are
very concerned about the project this
started in 1992 and we're still not
breaking ground yet so
what have been some of the delays
because we heard that tunnel could delay
at six months or a year but we're
talking Decades of delay yeah that was
mostly the financing side of things uh
federal dollars
um Senator Shaheen when she was a
governor actually put money into the
into the project and somehow eventually
it was actually taken away you know it's
been a long long process
um
the fact of the matter is is you know
I'm going to pinch myself that it's here
because a lot of people from my town was
like it's never going to happen never
right and from my standpoint I don't
really have I use the rail trail I think
it's great it's a great it's a great
thing it's a great resource
I'll use it if it's a tunnel and I'll
use it if it's a path for me
my main concern is dairy has been known
for high tax rates over the years we're
getting much better much much better
however we have 80 a mix of 80
residential and 20 commercial we need to
offset our residential taxes so economic
development is really in the Forefront
for us
so this does two things we have new
commercial development off of this exit
and then we can redevelop our downtown
which is old and need some Redevelopment
we've got people that are interested to
do some housing
um so I'm kind of excited to see the
project move forward I really don't want
to see delays because I've seen so many
of them
but
so if we could make you King for the day
and
with the tunnel be on your list if
someone else paid for it other than the
well obviously if someone else is going
to give me a gift that I'm fine with
that
um but if it's going to delay
there's there's numbers on the other
side of that you know
um it's not just to clear whether you
want the tunnel or not it's it's got the
delay piece
um which is a costly thing
uh some of us spoke I believe to a
representative represented representing
the uh large development over in
Londonderry yeah that's Woodmont
Woodmont Orchards and he pointed out
that the real Trill obviously would be
it's good for them it's a selling point
we heard from
folks sit down in the Salem area that
there's many as 166
000 people that use this Corridor and of
course as you know the corridor the plan
is to connect it all the way to White
River Junction or Lebanon so it's going
to be a huge economic as already has
been a huge economic development for
that area so trying to get through this
tunnel so to speak
kind of puts a
some icing on the cake because that's a
little piece between Londonderry your
town and Salem it doesn't exist so just
a little tidbit I did five terms as a
State Rep here from 2010 to 2020. I was
named to be on a special committee I
think it was SB 89
it was me representative Sykes from
transportation and Senator Stiles
dealing with rail trails
so we spent over 12 different meetings
talking about real Trails so I fully
understand the concept
I think it's great if we can connect all
the way up to Lebanon I think it's a
major plus I think it is a benefit
um the whole system is and it's very
well used so I do admit that and I use
well again I don't see any other further
comments I really appreciate you taking
the time I appreciate it thank you yeah
yes sir I don't did you speak before to
us or you did not I didn't recognize you
you please take the mic everything's
recorded So
okay there we go uh thank you very much
for allowing me to speak I'm sorry I
know you're winding down uh your
testimony but um I was the chairman of
the dairy Town Council when we turned
this project over to the Department of
Transportation so I I know a little bit
about it I've followed the the project
for over 25 years and
I'm sorry uh Thomas Cardin
and that's car Don
[Music]
thank you sir
um and so I have I've lived in Dairy for
33 years I've followed the 4A project
for 25 years and
um sent numerous letters to the editor
and all the other agencies and involved
in this and as I said before I was
chairman of the Town Council when we
turned this over to the dot dot approach
to town and you know we agreed to do
this and
um you know the the owners of the of the
property where the towns go is
Mr chuchello said I had spoken with him
before we turned this over to to the dot
and I said specifically what about the
tunnel and he said the tunnel would be a
part of that Tom don't worry about it
and so we we have gone into this project
all along that the town's going to be
part of it and
um you know I know the the Town Council
voted they voted in favor of the
taxpayers
um to not pay for it uh if I had been on
the Town Council at the time
um my response would have been uh I
would have sent the dot a letter saying
no we are not interested in paying for
this this is an important part of our
town and there's been numerous uh people
speaking in an outgrowing of support for
the tunnel project
um
you know and that the whole reason that
um you know the Town Council turned this
project over to the D.O.T was that we
didn't want to get to a point where we
are now
and there'd be more surprises more more
money costs that are going to be
downshifted and that's basically what
the the dot is doing their uh they're
downshifting
um they're downshifting their costs to
the town of dairy and it's it's really
not fair uh one of the one of the things
about the rail trail is it's really the
Cornerstone for economic development in
Dairy it runs through the downtown uh
the rail trail has done a tremendous
amount of work they spent a lot of money
raised a lot of money
to get it to a point like this and you
know it's going to be a destination for
the downtown and you know in all honesty
the the people that use that rail trail
you know they deserve an easy safe
access and you know as a couple of you
said before people aren't going to use
the spaghetti path when they come to
that they're going to go right over
right across those six Lanes of Highways
and that would be
um that would be a big problem oh and
also I just wanted to to very quickly
address the delays this project has been
delayed for I mean I know go at least 15
years
um like I said I've followed it for many
years it began in
1985. I started following closely in the
mid 90s my daughter was in high school
she is now 45 years old and her oldest
son is in uh is in college so the laser
delays are are been part of this project
for years and years and years and
especially cost overruns I mean think
about it in 2000 in 1997 I attended the
meeting when
um when the Town Council approved the
five million dollar Bond it was supposed
to be 10 million dollars here we are
um here we are today and I spoke with uh
Wendy Johnson at the at the last meeting
and I asked her how much the project was
going to be and she said uh right now
it's 112 million dollars and I said to
her I said well how much is it going to
cost and she said I don't know and I
responded to her I said well I know I
said I followed this project it goes up
an average of four million dollars a
year so you can use that as your
Baseline and you know since since the
Town Council turned this over to the dot
the project has gone up
um I don't know 50 to 53 million dollars
no thank you
thank you very much very good testimony
thank you thanks for the history
uh I'll be happy to answer any questions
yes uh what represents sweetie
all right no problem
yes I see the chairman of the Public
Works committee back there and
remind everybody where
getting laid into the afternoon
and you have a hard name to spell so you
better
every time I sit in your chair I I think
mines is probably the easiest that would
I have distinct pleasure of chairing uh
Public Works and highways I first came
here in 2020 I've served nine terms
before that I had 10 years in the
regional Planning Commission I was a
member of the TAC and the tack is where
as you know that's where all projects
start in the 10-year plan you're vetted
in your area a project is scored moves
on
hearings are held by D.O.T moves on to
the executive Council they hear the
proposals they rank them and then they
land on our desk in public works next
year and then we we will go through
there I was somewhat surprised
that this bill came through your
committee
and did not come through Public Works
and highways many of the items you're
struggling with we deal in a a daily uh
yearly basis all the time one of our
stars is sitting to my left over here
that I served with for many years
I also started and financed a bike path
in my area I'm a little further north I
will not propose to be the North country
so I have great Sympathy for the people
in the room here
but the truth of the matter is if people
break the protocol people towns expand
the scope of a plan that was approved
and in place
and then ask for in this case by the
time you put the engineering cost and
the construction costs it's nearly a
million dollars and every time they can
circumvent the process and take a
million dollars away there's a million
dollars less that my little towns are
going to be able to find also so you
folks have a tremendous chore in front
of you I would probably propose to
retain
but I want to thank you for giving me
the opportunity to speak in front of you
good to see you thank you are there any
questions for the chair Public Works
so just one quick question for you folks
at the D.O.T
how many feet the Scenic Trail that you
have going down along Shield Brook how
many feet is that do you know off the
top of your head because the town of
dairy will have to maintain that right
and the all the improvements like the
bridges and signals that will all be the
responsibility of the town of dairy is
that correct you're asking how along the
detour the additional distance this is
all right uh yes sir if one more
individual and then we've got to move
along and make a decision one way or the
other
I don't think you spoke though did you
no
again if you could state your name
please for the record
my name is Wayne Morris m-o-r-r-i-s
um what I have here just a couple of
pictures that were taken on the real
Trail
basically showing the users
um
dog walkers
families with bicycles you know that
they pack up and they they bring the
whole the whole family to the rail trail
um
and then also
the
uses
um with persons with disabilities this
this is actually take from the website
of uh Northeast passage
so I will leave that here and I think
Dave has Dave has a letter that I will
reference
well I'll get to that yeah
um but well I need to know just okay uh
again my name is Wayne Morris I'm a
board member of the Granite State Rail
Trail
as well as vice president and a founding
member of the Windham rail trail
Alliance
prior to my retirement I was a physical
therapist for 45 years where I dealt
with accessibility issues for persons of
all ages
foreign
safe accessible transportation and
Recreation for persons with disabilities
led me to become involved in real Trail
issues some 20 years ago
last week the Department of
Transportation assured you and again
they assured you today thanks that the
spaghetti plan provided a safe
alternative to the tunnel option and met
all ADA requirements
accessibilities is about more than
compliance with standards
it's about developing solutions to meet
the needs of all users again all users
here with and without disabilities
these Solutions are all components of
Universal Design
a concept now widely used in the private
sector and provides a path for federal
agencies to shift to this broader Focus
Universal Design minimizes hazards and
the adverse consequences of accidental
or unintended actions
the spaghetti plan
with this
three 90 degree turns on a downslope
inadequate sight distances
under a bridge
a 180 degree uh
button hook turn on a five degree slope
um
it's five percent grade for 550 feet
almost two football fields without any
areas for resting intervals at least
that I saw
then another five percent grade for 430
feet
again without any resting intervals
will not minimize hazards and the
adverse consequences of accidental or
unintended actions but rather increases
the risk of those happening
and again I'll I'll refer to this
picture
550 feet a person pedaling a tricycle
with their arms
it's not going to happen
you're just disenfranchising a huge
portion of the population not only
physically handicapped but also a lot of
the elderly are not going to be able to
use this I know the the assistant
commissioner said oh no I think it was
the Town Council said that um he he
would use both the tunnel and the uh in
the spaghetti plan well I'm here to tell
you I won't use a spaghetti plan because
I can't
um because of my medical conditions I
will use the tunnel and that's why you
know real trails are so attractive to
most people because of the one to two
percent grade you throw in a five
percent grade with all these issues
you've got major problems major problems
that are going to happen
um
let's see the tunnel option with its two
to three percent grade or less for a
short distance
um and again I'll refer back to last
week
um
dot made the statement that the tunnel
option also includes five percent grades
I don't believe it does I think we have
plans that show that it doesn't
um so that's a misnomer
um the tunnel will be usable by all
people to the greatest extent possible
without the need for add that patient A
specialized design
Northeast Passage
and adaptive Sports and therapeutic
recreation organization based out of the
University of New Hampshire
supported the tunnel option in a letter
to the Derry Town Town Council which I I
don't know if it was handed out dated
December 19th they stated that the
tunnel favors Universal Design and will
always advocate in supporting the use of
these projects for people of all
abilities
this organization uses the Wyndham
section of the Granite State Rail Trail
because
um bringing with them an assortment of
adapted to Cycles Recumbent Trikes
tandem cycles and a hand cycle like like
is pictured here specifically because of
the real Trails gentle raid
in closing the Department of
Transportation has a chance to do the
right thing right from the get-go
by building the tunnel
option which meets the needs of all
people that is accessible usable
convenient and a pleasure to use I
believe building
the spaghetti option
will result in a stain on the New
Hampshire Department's well-earned
National reputation of Designing
top-notch infrastructure projects thank
you
thank you very much for your testimony
uh was it Morris right correct any
seeing none thank you thank you very
much
any thoughts the division have any
thoughts and what we'd like to do with
this yes representative Sweeney thank
you Mr chairman um I think I can say at
this point I'm not sure where I would go
on the legislature I I would amend it to
get rid of the misdemeanor but I think
the overar the underlying legislation uh
I'm not sure
no pun intended but where the best path
is for for this I'd be happy to offer
time working on it
uh retain the bill and
well I don't I don't know if retaining
makes sense if that's just going to push
it out and we actually we don't have to
make a decision today we could say let's
meet next week get more information
maybe all the members would like to go
down to the site could do that too and
only push out a week or something
special another hearing I think that
makes sense just so that we can make
sure everybody that wants to be heard
gets a chance to be heard on this great
suggestion
would you uh we're we're actually
discussing a procedure so we're not
going to take any further testimony
point out that there's people that did
take time off of work to come here at
your request and there's only a couple
of them I was wondering if you give them
each three minutes for those that want
to speak
um
well I I think we're going to have
another meeting it's it's getting late
um
in all fairness to everybody uh I
apologize for any of you that have come
a long distance but I believe
representative Sweeney's suggestions are
good we need more information hopefully
we'll get it and if anyone wishes to
come in a week they can so is that
you're okay with that
I I share uh representative Sweeney's
uh thoughts on this as far as I'm not
really ready to make a decision on it
I've heard a lot of things on both sides
of the issue here today
what I haven't heard is a clear
Unified
decision
from the dairy Council
and it's really
we're sitting up here in Concord
and I don't think we should be making
decisions for the town may have their
own just they have their own
Representatives they'd entered into a
contract
with the DOT
and shot of uh you know a clear
message from the Town Council
anyone else wish to comment
representative evil thank you very much
Mr chair I just want to follow up on
what representative Griffin said I think
that it's very difficult
for a legislative body to come into the
middle of a project that's had so much
discussion and as much fact-finding as
we
try to do
one of the difficulties of being in a
position like this is that you can never
fully satisfy yourself I I just there's
just too much I am struck by the
September 26
2022 letter from David Karen to Dot
and it says right here is previously
stated by our elected officials here in
Derry We Believe Dot's plan to provide
safe Passage through the corridor by
means of a shared use pathway is an
efficient reasonable and rational basis
of all stakeholders associated with the
project
I think that's a pretty clear statement
they met again in January they had
everything presented again they didn't
change their position and as one who's
pretty interested in local control I for
one would be really uncomfortable
stepping on the toes of the town of
rhc yes representative Kimbrell's yes I
had to representative Sweeney's Point
um I I believe that there's no Mal
intent on either side of the parties
here and for that reason I would want to
adopt the amendment to
eliminate the misdemeanor Char charges
all right
Instagram
representative Hewitt sure
first of all
I want to repeat something I said about
a previous bill
I frankly don't understand the uh the
process including of the finance
committee deciding whether what is going
to be billed and what is not going to be
built sorry uh and uh in addition to
that I've been reading through some of
these things and it it occurs to me that
there have been some decisions made and
some for example this contract that was
made between the uh between the towns
and the Department of Transportation
uh which
cast some on on unusual light on this
situation uh the the contract was uh
signed by everybody and also approved by
the Attorney General governor and
Council
and
I don't see where where we have the the
right to decide which process is going
to be used I'm not saying I'm not saying
that you can't I'm saying that this is a
situation where we really should not
make any decisions until we've had an
opportunity uh to look at all the facts
and the information that's been provided
to us today which we haven't had a
chance to read
thank you representative Hewitt
representative cambrells has made a
motion to take out their misdemeanor
charges and the Stapleton amendment I
believe it's seconded by representative
Sweeney
when the clerk is ready
this is for um
Amendment forthcoming that takes out
away any uh
okay
all right so
20230179h on House Bill 506 FN as stated
that takes away the penalty
um
as as stated and a yay will
um the affirmative and a negative uh
representative McGuire yeah
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative rules yes
votes yes
uh representative Hewitt no
representative
evil
yes
and chairman Leachman
and
um
seven to one
thank you Mr clerk so we will be again
meeting uh I don't know the date yet but
it will be sometime next week so please
pay attention to the house calendar
thank you all for your patience and
showing up today
and uh if there's any additional
information you think that would be
helpful please forward it to our